foreign
as a security leak accidentally put out
on Twitter Senator John cornyn claimed
the U.S has 30 000 troops in Taiwan that
is uh well according to Newsweek and
other fact Checkers and probably most
people not true the US doesn't have 30
000 troops stationed in Taiwan but uh
certainly people in Chinese media and
pro-chinese Communist Party are acting
like oh oh they've accidentally revealed
that they've invaded Chinese space okay
well this may have been Senator cornyn
slipping on a banana peel and
accidentally starting World War III
because China says that would be a
declaration of war they would invoke the
secession act and immediately invade and
Destroy U.S forces if they were in
Taiwan
yikes man at a time when there's chaos
in Afghanistan and the US is looking
particularly weak and then this happens
well this happened probably because
China's taking advantage of the fact
that we look weak they've also issued a
statement through their state media that
to Taiwan when they invade to reunify
with military force the U.S will not be
there to protect them so we're gonna get
into other stuff we'll talk about
Afghanistan we'll talk about what's
going on this International conflict
because we've got a couple of vets here
who can help us get into it but we also
got news about New York we got really
interesting news that following uh these
stories palantir
announced that they're going to be
investing 50 million dollars in gold in
case of a potential Black Swan event so
when there's a company that does like
data analysis and their name is
effectively like a fantasy is based on a
fantasy seeing Stone and then they're
like there's going to be a Black Swan
event maybe so we're buying a bunch of
gold and our clients can now pay us in
Gold I'm kind of like what did they just
see in their data so I don't know maybe
I want to buy some gold but uh we'll get
into all this stuff we're hanging out a
couple people we got you episode but hey
hey ladies and gentlemen we just broke
the news earlier tonight that Joe Biden
is going to be heading back to
Wilmington tomorrow uh the FAA has
confirmed this on their website uh what
I was being told was that he is not
getting good sleep in the white house
doesn't like it there prefers to sleep
at home Joe Biden if you really want a
good night oh my gosh
don't do it
is to head over to mypillow.com
utilize promo code poso for up to 66 off
and Mr President you will get the best
night's sleep in the whole wide world
but no so that that was something that I
was actually told earlier today I
tweeted it out and then the FAA put it
up on their website that he isn't even
putting in on this week of all weeks
he's not putting in a full week of work
that he is heading back to Wilmington
and he's going to be having a long
weekend there yeah I mean Trump had a
lot of long weekends in Mar-A-Lago he
calls it the winter white house you know
but uh I think now is not the time for a
vacation I can put it that you know for
all the criticism we can make about past
administrations let's just stick to it
Joe Biden please work I guess I mean
that's something a lot of people get
were you know wanted to politicize it
but you know oh what about you and
golfing et cetera Etc but it's like
you're the guy who's there now just
right that that picture that came out
you know of the situa or it wasn't even
The Situation Room it's Camp David and
he's just surrounded by nothing right
he's just sitting there in a room by
himself I don't exactly think that
inspired confidence I don't know if and
then people are questioning the the the
the amount of Chaos in the white house
right now the the lines of communication
by the way between the White House the
Pentagon the state department it's
completely free yeah you had a source
you were tweeting about this let's get
into that we'll talk about it and I've
actually saved some stuff for for just
all right perfect we got Forrest hanging
out yeah so I don't have like a my
pillow ad thank you we can just do mine
again I can do yours again uh or get in
the pillow don't hit me with it uh so no
uh my name is Forrest Cooper I'm the
digital Newsroom editor for Recoil
magazine and we are a firearms and
Firearms culture uh publication we also
cover we've got off-grid concealment
uh recoil and then we also have
carnivore which is for high-end hunting
and so I am I represent the digital side
and something that you're going to find
out about us is the broad majority of
our editorial board we're all veterans
so my military experience is third
ranger battalion I was a team leader
there and so I I got to see Afghanistan
pretty close you were trying to teach
some of these guys weren't you there
were definitely well there's definitely
times where any many different groups
within the military had the opportunity
to teach different levels of the Afghan
people and yes there were there was a
time where I was actually trying to
teach the Afghan what they would
consider Afghan special horses yeah so
that was that'll be interesting talk
Rangers lead the way yeah yeah thank you
and uh I am I am intimately familiar
with the city of Kabul so perfect right
on right on we got Ian it's an
interesting you phrase at the time you
spend there you are trying to teach the
people
yeah measures of success
let's find out right yeah we'll get into
that in a bit we got lady present
buttons I am in the corner pushing
buttons as always I'm very excited about
this because we got the expert on China
we got the expert on Afghanistan we got
the Navy and the Army representing I'm
stuck it's gonna be a great show thank
you my friends before we get started we
have an awesome sponsor BioTrust keto
Elevate go to eat right and feelwell.com
and you can get 51 off of BioTrust keto
Elevate that's right it's right here it
is their C8 medium chain triglyceride
oil powder what is this for it's for
when you're doing keto or you're trying
to cut out the sugar trying to eat
healthy this stuff is fantastic you're
mixing your drink gives it kind of like
a creamy feel and let me tell you I've
accidentally been doing keto because we
went to the store for we're doing a vlog
and we bought a whole bunch of meat and
cheese because we'll do charcuterie oh
yeah let's also get fruit and whipped
cream and now we got tons of whipped
cream so I've been guzzling whipped
cream and meat and cheese and I was like
you know what this keto stuff actually
feels really good and so after the first
cut like the first day I just felt like
a million bucks I'm like I think I'm
gonna start cutting out these sugars and
these grains and just eating there you
go there you go and I'm gonna start
using this stuff more and more and more
because this stuff's already good I
already love throwing it in my smoothies
and my drinks now I'm not going to be
doing the smoothies I'm gonna be
throwing it into other drinks maybe just
my water but check it out go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com get your keto
Elevate powder and bio trust says you
get a 60-day money-back guarantee they
uh keto Elevate provides your body with
only C8 the most ketogenic MCT that
means it provides support for energy
levels healthy appetite Management
Mental Clarity and focus athletic
performance five grams of the highly
sought after mctc8 per scoop you to
elevate it's my favorite MCT powder um
to be honest the only one I use free
shipping on every order and for every
order today BioTrust donates a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor to their partnership with no
kidhungry.org to date bio trust has
provided over 5 million meals to Hungry
kids please help BioTrust hit their goal
of six million meals this year you also
get free VIP live health and fitness
coaching from BioTrust team of expert
nutrition and health coaches for life
with every order and their free e-report
to the top 14 ketogenic foods with every
order again go to EatRight and
feelwell.com bio trust you guys rock we
love your stuff and we just got some new
stuff sent in we're all huge fans Ian's
always put in this car oh yeah I'm gonna
put I haven't yet today but I'm about to
let me try to slide that over and uh
don't forget go to timcast.com become a
member we're gonna have a members only
segment coming up usually goes live
around 11 or so p.m we record it after
the show and when you're a member you're
supporting our Fierce and independent
journalism we've got some uh some
research being done right now on the
food shortages that are hitting you may
have seen my tweet about it we'll talk
about it maybe later on in the show but
we're we're tracking this trying to
figure out where the holes are because
there's you know Nando's in the UK this
this restaurant shut down 50 locations
due to the chicken shortage this food
shortages is serious it's hitting across
uh you know all sectors in the US and
the UK we'll get into that again Tim
catch dot com don't forget to like this
video subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends press that
share button grab that URL do it for a
little Ian do it who sits here every day
just wishing and also smash the like
button I do it for you do it for me
let's talk about China all right we're
gonna talk about China because I really
want to talk about Afghanistan but the
big news is what the Ripple of
Afghanistan means for the rest of us
because of the failure in the withdrawal
from Afghanistan I mean it's absolute
chaos they're trying to make it seem
like it's it's good it's not good it's
not good China is taking advantage and
we have this article from the fake News
global times it's China's mouthpiece
saying update Senator reveals 30 000 U.S
troops stationed in Taiwan Island equal
to declaring war on China if it's true
tweet deleted after wide controversy so
it seems that Senator John cornyn just
didn't know what he was talking about
the Taiwan number that there's 30 000
troops there apparently it's an old
number going back to the 70s or whatever
but China's not acting like it was just
a dumb tweet from someone who wasn't
paying attention they're trying to make
it seem like he revealed the information
look at this they say some others
believe the news leaked by the U.S
senator cannot be true because 30 000 is
not some small amount the US Army could
hide and not being noticed on the island
and the U.S has nothing to gain by
stationing the US Army in the island
sacrificing its own interest to satisfy
taiwan's separatists also does not fit
with U.S foreign policy just like the
U.S did in Afghanistan
talk about getting smacked around quite
a bit by China right now ouch yeah I
mean you don't usually see the ccps and
their mouthpieces being so publicly
um
I would just say you know trading barbs
back and forth especially in with you
know kind of operating within the news
cycle as we are right now so this is
definitely something new for the CCP
this is not something that you even four
years ago five years ago you would see
them doing only it's because now and I
think with Xi Jinping and his new thrust
for a more uh a more aggressive China on
the world stage a more you know we're
not going to be this we don't want to be
viewed as a third world country anymore
so for years and years and years we were
told China is still developing China is
still you know we're bringing our people
out of poverty we need all these
programs but then if you just look uh I
believe yesterday the financial times
actually had the story up that BlackRock
came out and said that they want to
increase their investors exposure to
China they want people tripling their
investments in China That's BlackRock
because they and they said that they
have sort of like an internal Think Tank
there they call it the BlackRock
investment Institute and they said we
don't don't view China as a developing
country anymore they are a fully
developed nation and we should treat
them the same way as we treat everyone
else they are an engine that is growing
they are the future that's essentially
what BlackRock is saying right and now
China they are now using this
opportunity as a way to shrug their
shoulders off of sort of the what you
know what Tony blinken or Joe Biden
might call the international rules-based
order they're shrugging off the WTO the
UN Etc everything else and they're
saying we are not going to be pushed
around by you anymore we're going to
push back think about how long it's been
that China's been effectively just
telling us to shove it where they know
that
man no matter what the U.S says it's
always a finger wagon so they're they're
met they're dumping all this pollution
they're producing massive amounts of
carbon while the rest of the world is
like Hey we're gonna stop hey we've got
these protocols we're all going to agree
to and China's like nah no thanks or
they say they will and then they start
building more coal power plants you've
got really dumb leadership in the west
where they're like it's okay guys China
said they're they're on board with our
programs and then China's is laughing
like why would we ever actually do what
we said and it's been happening for a
really really long time that's a really
good description especially if you're
going to go into Afghanistan later but
starting with China like as a country
they take themselves seriously yeah
there's another thing that China has
that America doesn't have right now is
that America is going through some sort
of identity crisis where it can't figure
out whether itself should exist anymore
I mean the scary thing is that's the
perfect way to put it yeah like it's the
perfect way it's it's going through
internal Mayhem why else wouldn't China
move if you're thinking about yourself
as two players on a chessboard and
you're watching your opponent run into
dismay
if not aiding it somehow or at least
prodding it along I don't you know you
could say that one way or another I mean
you could ask questions of International
International influence and terrorism
and you could go out on those roads but
instead just instead of just accusing
China of participating in domestic
terrorism within the world stage they're
like they will make an agreement that
they know they won't follow because they
don't respect you as an interlocutor
right right so what what essentially
you're talking about is this idea that
you know I don't think China China knows
that it's not into their best interest
to get into a shooting war with the US
right the kinetic Warfare is not
something that would be really
beneficial for either side and so that
what is the most effective right tool of
their International foreign policy for
their interests is what you would call
Strategic neutralization right get the
US so upset so divided so screaming at
each other so tied up in it chasing its
own tail in internal domestic tensions
that we are unable to make a stand on
the world stage and we said that I came
on here and said that for a year on this
show and I've said it elsewhere and then
you look at Afghanistan see we're so
busy and I mean it's almost a cliche
right now but you've got General milley
talking about white rage and we need to
focus on critical race Theory etc etc
and then meanwhile it's like you can't
even conduct a basic evacuation operator
duration of your own or not even before
that I I'm getting ahead of myself you
can't even conduct a safe withdrawal of
your own forces right you didn't know
which then set up right this was
supposed to be withdrawal this wasn't
supposed to be an evacuation operation
it's only be we're only talking about an
evacuation because it was a failure so
for China this is exactly what they want
now they get to backfill us in
Afghanistan now they get to go after the
rare earth minerals now they get to buy
up all that stuff of course they're
making a deal with with the Taliban
however and this is my assessment I've
thrown it out there I'll say it again
tonight but I think that you will see
Taliban attacking China's one belt one
road infrastructure within or you know
maybe not specifically Taliban but other
extremist elements over there within
five years uh that's just the history of
the region that's the history of the
peoples of that region you do not see
occupying Nations occupying force is
doing well in that part of the world and
and there's a lot of history about it I
I have a kind of a caveat unless China
does manifest the oppressor oppressed
narrative within the Afghan people and
say
it's not hard you can like when when
we're on the ground we experienced that
with the locals oh you're you're not the
Americans you're the oppressors okay is
that what they said when so of course
yeah no no it's it's yeah it's already
there the the the language is already
invested in the system and they already
have the easy example of all America's
the big bad why wouldn't China
motivate that at that that cultural
aspect remember China the current CCP
was created by Mao maoist China was this
idea of manifesting the political
disdain of the people for their own
government now you just use China doing
that on the world stage manifesting
government countries or pseudo countries
against
ambiguous ideas like the West like rule
of law like America like I I would not
be surprised I think it buys them a
couple years I think I I think they can
get a couple years out of using that
very narrative and as well going with
the Taliban and saying we there you know
they are def I don't think they've
officially recognized a Taliban and
um wrong I don't believe anyone has
officially recognized them yet China has
come the closest but even then I think
it's something more they said like we
acknowledge the will of the Afghan
people rather than we we recognize the
taliban's legitimate government so I
think it buys them a couple years
obviously it's it's in their best
interest taliban's interest to receive
if they can get any kind of deals with
China if they can get banking if they
can get all this because of course
you're seeing a lot of the International
Community trying to shut down any uh
aspect of the Taliban getting into the
finances of the government of
Afghanistan and being able to use any of
this stuff and so for China it creates
this sort of Wellspring for them of
having that that ability to not have to
use the International System because
they can just go through China so
China's try as you say they're trying to
set themselves up as we are the
benefactor to go against the big bad of
the West and I do think that'll buy them
some time but there's this 2 000 years
of history of Afghanistan being the
graveyard of Empires not to mention if
they're going to try and make it seem
like oh the West is bad they're they're
the real enemies they're also trying to
make the world think that we've lost our
power their their their their their
attitude is the US is fading the Empire
is collapsing we're the big bad we're
next
so I don't know if they would want to
convey that message simultaneously while
they're trying to convince everyone the
U.S is failing Robert Tabor the classic
war of the flea I'm not I'm not an
expert on on his work alone but the
introductory paragraphs are Insurgency
is prolonged political Warfare it
creating the spirit of Revolution which
runs on the idea that it could happen
right so you don't so so Afghanistan or
China does not endorse the Taliban they
endorse the Afghan caliphate right which
is the Chinese puppet of that attaches
themselves to movements like the Nation
of Islam then enters Western countries
and uses that as a backdoor Road into
pushing more disdain for Western values
and then the real question though is
what happens if and they are talking
about setting up an Islamic Republic
um or believe examic Emirate I think is
the is the official name it's like
they're like Republic no the Islamic I
understand so how do you have an Islamic
Emirate but when right across your
border with China is what region of
China xinjiang yeah xinjiang which is I
think three times the stat one Province
three times the size of Afghanistan
um nowhere near as populated as
Afghanistan but it's massively bigger
than Afghanistan and you have one
million weaker Muslims also Sunni by the
way
um who are kept in concentration camps
by your same benefactor essentially you
get once you see these narrative
conflicts these contradictions I think
are what will eventually cause problems
in this relationship because China is
going to to say well we're here to help
you okay but what about our you know our
friends our brothers that are within
your land that you are pressing so that
you can build your pipelines across
Pakistan you know I've heard some
stories about what China is doing and I
kind of feel like the Islamic Emirate of
Afghanistan would not mind so I don't
know if you've heard these stories that
what they when they harvest organs from
the uyghurs they can then sell them to
Arabic Nations who need organ
transplants that are in halal yeah yeah
I don't know if that's true if you're
for anything like that so essentially
essentially what I'm saying though is
that
you will get you will still end up
getting Breakaway groups right you're
still going to end up getting a group
there because this is the nature of
radical Islam is that you will have a
group that says how dare we be in bed
with these guys how dare we go along
with this they are atheists they are
communists they are from the same stripe
as the Soviet Union when they try to
impose Communists on us now you're
trying to get in bed with a new the new
Communists who oppress our people and
that's where you're going to get this
friction do you think with these threats
coming from China not only for the
military force against Taiwan but also
to crush U.S troops assuming they're
only there I think we have like 20
there's like you know 20 military
personnel who are in Taiwan for some
like training exercises uh do you think
this leads to war
um look I've I've you know I'm I'm sort
of like the proverbial I don't think
we're going to go to a shooting war with
Taiwan anytime soon over Taiwan anytime
soon that being said it's possible right
um I don't think it's in China's best
interest I don't think it's in our best
interests again remember the plan right
the we the axis of the elites between
the CCP and the one percent in the west
we want you to become the consumer
Nation they want the West to be the
consumers of the world our inflated uh
consumer values our dollars we want you
to buy our TVs we want you to buy our
iPhones everything that's made in China
you you are to consume that and be happy
remember right you'll own nothing and
you'll be happy yeah but that that burst
so
but it's still to your interest to
continue it going for as long as
possible yeah and then if we can if we
can condition down your to your point if
we can condition down your National will
your national identity if you don't feel
as strongly as being able to stand up
for your allies you'll then eventually
you'll get to the point to say well why
would we go to war over Taiwan right who
cares about this thing and then so for
Chinese perspective again it's it's
similar to the to the Taliban in a sense
there's that phrase that's been going
around this week you know you have the
watches but we have the time right right
so it was a hundred years for Hong Kong
and that 1897 to 1997 right and that
Handover of Taiwan is seen by the way as
the end of the British Empire many
people see that as the end of the
British Empires the symbolic act that
okay we are no longer this this
International what about Empire what
about Macau that's that's China Chinese
yeah I think Macau is 99 so that was
that was uh Portugal so and that was
about two years later but Hong Kong of
course was a big one though right if you
actually look at it in terms of rev of
local Revenue I believe Macau is
actually ahead I know they're way above
Las Vegas in terms of gambling Revenue
that is the gambling center of the world
right now is Macau really oh yeah oh
yeah 100 and and so and you better
believe that a lot of the companies from
Vegas are all still operating in Macau
which means they're all tied in with CCP
as well and so you've got a situation
where you know to the ccp's perspective
they want to assimilate Taiwan through
osmosis the strategy has been isolate
isolate them throughout the world cut
off their trade cut up their finances
right so if you land I've been you know
I've been to Taiwan I've been on both
sides of the Taiwan Strait actually
and uh you know looked across you can't
see it but you know
um and so you when you land in the
Taipei airport you know usually when you
land somewhere there's you see what's
the first thing you see is
advertisements right you see advertising
it's usually Banks or some kind of real
estate or something like that
in the Taipei airport there's none of
that right there's just a couple
pictures up of Taiwan from like the
local you know mystery of Tourism and
that's it so there aren't those huge
International brands
playing in Taiwan the way that you'd see
everywhere else and why is that that's
because of economic isolationism that's
Beijing going around telling everybody
you don't do business with this island
because we want their only economic
social and cultural Vector to be through
us and if you want access to our markets
if you want access to be able to sell if
you want all the deals that we can offer
you right you have to cut off Taiwan
that is the price you have to pay and
that's why if you go back to the 1970s
that is why the US government recognized
recognized the government of Beijing for
the first time for all those years
throughout the Cold War we didn't
recognize them and it was Carter who
eventually switched that over which then
had the pro had the the after effect of
changing the seat at the United Nations
which was controlled by Taiwan the
Republic of China which was and is the
legitimate government of China uh prior
to the CCP then that seat at the U.N
security Council went to communist China
so uh what's a Black Swan event
question yeah I'll jump I'll jump into
this one so one of the the title of the
Blackstone event is most often
attributed to Nicholas Naseem to Leb
um now he is a he's both an economist
he's been he's a professor he's he's an
author he's kind of one of those Auto
phages he's accomplished many things
um but he um he wrote a book called The
Black Swan and the idea of a Black Swan
event is something it is a large event a
large catastrophic or a large event of
of a very effective proportions whatever
that either a could not have been
predicted or B if it would have been
predicted it wouldn't have happened and
therefore would never have been noticed
and so he when he opens up uh I think
it's when he opens up his book The Black
Swan he is using the example of
uh 911. so if a person had if anybody in
the airports had said it's strange that
these people have these items and just
simply taken them
then there would have been no 911
interesting
and no one would have heard they
wouldn't have been promoted they
wouldn't have been made into generals or
Heroes it was just like all of these
little things had to happen in a row
where it ended up in a catastrophe that
no one predicted because it's a
cascading failure yeah I'm not going to
use the word cascading failure because
I'm not going to be specific on that one
but you might be correct in the sense of
that one where well there's that story
of um it's uh Jose Melendez Perez was
the was the one TSA agent um who had
been I think it was um is a Puerto Rican
uh served in I think Vietnam and he was
the one who stopped um
supposedly the 20th hijacker
um in from coming through in Florida and
because he just and I always remember
the story because it was like
he just seemed he just says that he
seemed off to me right this guy got put
in secondary screening and you know
because he didn't he he wasn't able to
answer the questions when you come in
you know hey where are you going how
long you staying when are you flying
back didn't have good answers to the
questions get put into secondary
screening and then Jose Melendez Perez
goes to see him and says look this this
guy's got military training I can see
he's got like a military bearing to him
and you know like you kind of know if
you've been in the military like hey
this guy's got you know and something
seems off his story seems off he doesn't
have a return ticket and then they
pulled him aside and they said hey man
these this guy's Saudi you got to be you
know you got to be PC you got to be
careful and
I'm on this Paris says I I don't care I
this guy everything that I'm supposed to
do says this guy shouldn't be allowed
into the United States so I'm going to
send him home and he did send him home
and he was supposed to be the muscle man
for
um for United 93 so that's why in 1993
only had four hijackers as opposed the
others that had five and he was supposed
to be one that was doing crowd control
for the the um the passengers as the as
the other guys flew and then
what they what Melinda's Paris didn't
know was that waiting to pick up
Muhammad al-katani in the you know the
parking lot of the airport in Florida
was Muhammad Atta who was the lead the
leader you know he was one guy he just
did what he was supposed to do just did
his job so here's why I asked from the
New York Post palantir buys 50 million
dollars worth of gold bars to counter
Black Swan event oh boy yeah uh so what
does palantir do
so palantir is I mean they're they're
like a database of databases if that
makes sense right so they are they are a
software which allows for database
integration and you know think of you
know and it I know this from you know
the Intel Community using it and that's
where I was able to get my fingers on on
the palantir system but you could you
really use it for any big any large data
set
um I know this is starting wall Street's
starting to use it more pharmaceutical
companies to try to use it more any of
these massive data sets and it's
basically like you know you think of any
like
um
online database where you're going
through files and then things are linked
to each other well this is It's
multimedia and one thing can pop up to
another it's all tied together you can
do aggregation I mean they are what you
know an and a palantir of course is from
Lord of the Rings and it's it's the Seer
it's kind of like Ian's you've got a
little you know that's Ian's palantir
right there right there it is there it
is it literally has a crystal ball it's
a crystal ball right the idea is like
yeah it's uh Lord of the Rings face time
yeah
yeah it's what it's what uh who was it
was it Mary or Pippin they saw it and
they grabbed it yeah so uh the Colorado
based company purchased 50.7 million
dollars worth of 100 ounce gold bars
sometime in August palantir said in a
short note buried in its 93-page second
quarter earnings report last week
there's a uh the company previously
announced that I would accept Bitcoin as
a form of payment though it hasn't said
that it's invested in any Bitcoin yet
unlike some other companies including
Elon musk's electric car firm Tesla uh
what what what is what are they what in
palantir is uh it's Peter Thiel oh I
know I know but I'm saying what's the
what's the Black Swan event that they're
seeing they have all this data they're
the Sears Stone and they're like we
think we need 50 million dollars in 100
ounce gold bars yeah I saw a meme where
they were what they say and they're not
like the guys on TV saying you know buy
gold yeah right William Devane
Sauron is buying gold you have to wonder
right what's going on what does Sauron
know yeah so I don't know what do you
guys think is it uh it's economic
they're they're hedging against economic
inflation is that all you think that's
like they know it's common so dude one
it's going to be magnitude but that's
not a Black Swan event one conversation
70 bucks that would be black one
conversation sort of a meta conversation
I've been having a few people you know
offline
um lately is if you just look like if
you take the last five years worth of
events and you kind of put them all
together but you look at them from
you know go through the mental exercise
of going 20 years in the future and then
looking back
these last five years just the amount of
upheaval and the quickness and speed
with which events have transpired it
sort of feels like the preface to
something right it almost feels like
you're reading you know this okay this
is the back story of how we which led us
up to the event it kind of feels like
you're on a roller coaster and it's that
the clinks are going slower and slower
are you sitting in the front or in the
back of the roller coaster they're
always a front end I'm in the front 100
you gotta 100 yeah sit behind you yeah I
want to know I want to know yeah I want
to watch it's a good view yeah
yeah I'm not a big roller coaster person
though it's kind of boring Peter thiel's
heavily invested in like Bitcoin uh
marketplaces and stuff so but so so what
does this mean you're saying you think
that it's going to be an economic
shock to the system there's going to be
a magnitude of of cost inflation like
times 10. that's what magnitudes are no
we're already seeing it we're already
seeing it we're going to see things that
cost six dollars cost 60. it's going to
be absolute that would be insane I don't
know it's gonna be guys do you guys
agree well I mean that that makes sense
as to why they were because I mean from
what you're saying goal that's why
they're buying gold right because it's
it's yes there's a Black Swan event but
it'll be tied to economics it'll be and
obviously you would buy gold as a hedge
against Fiat so the idea that yeah and
that it now it may also be though that
they're they're not quite sold on crypto
yet and they're thinking that look you
know we kind of went through the
pandemic and and you know there were you
know there were times where crypto
seemed like it was people were using it
as a store of value but other times
where it seemed like it was crashing
along with the stock market because
there's a lot of speculation in crypto
as well and so
um it's not an awkward crypto Twitter by
the way you know it's all the crypto
Bros out there
um but it just I'm just talking about
how it went last year and so so you've
got to think that that From palantir's
perspective they want to go with the
more traditional store of value that
people have run to in a crisis and
that's gold what what would be a black
metal what would be a Black Swan event
that would hit the economy in in such a
way that they would need 50 million
dollars of gold bars they could print
120 trillion dollars tomorrow right but
is that a Black Swan event it would turn
out it would create a Black Swan does
that make sense no no you make a good
point would the printing of 100 trillion
dollars be the cause of the black Black
Swan event or would it be the event
itself good call because was 911 was it
the response to the buildings coming
down that was the real Black Swan event
like the war or was it the actual
building how do you define was it the
fact well maybe I think in that one
would be was the Black Swan event at uh
the thing that contributed to what we
call the Black Swan event of 9 11 was
the towers coming down but the things
that contributed to that are all of the
subsequent or the all the preceding
events that no one predicted no one
thought anyone was gonna hijack a
personnel carrier well actually so maybe
the formation of the feminism
I'm pretty sure they had uh
uh they had done drills specifically uh
mentioning this it's been a long time
since I've read you know a lot of the
news but I think the new I think I just
mean to say that it was a failure on the
part of the government and it's it's
kind of like when I mean certainly
hijackings had taken place oh yeah yeah
but it's when Biden says we plan for
every contingency we know they didn't no
you didn't right yeah and when they said
like oh who I think it was like I don't
know it was a Condoleezza Rice at the
time like who could have predicted they
would do this it's like the US did not
specifically but they knew that planes
could be used as Weapons look at this
last weekend in Afghanistan that was a
Black Swan event because we're like okay
well we I mean anybody who's been there
knows has some expectation that as the
as America recedes somebody's gonna fill
that void and if it's not the Afghan
military the Afghan government at the
time it's going to be somebody else and
who's that going to be it's obviously
going to be the Taliban we just did not
expect it the Black Swan event was that
they precipitated on across the country
so quickly
and so that's kind of you the multiple
layers of failures of of me of the
relationships with the local people not
on the individual level but on the state
level and how do we how do do are we
looking at this social investment in the
country and taking it seriously well no
so I I read a bit about Afghanistan and
what uh I can't remember I don't know
who wrote this they said that the U.S
polled air support and as soon as that
happened that's the centerpiece of
American Military strategy so they give
the Afghan Security Forces you know
these air capabilities but then Biden's
like we're pulling support and we're out
well there was actually an interesting
uh and it kind of ties into what you're
saying there is an interesting angle to
that because it was something along the
lines of and I don't want to get this
wrong but the idea was that we were
maintaining the Afghan Air Force and
they didn't have the capacity to their I
am using buzzwords capacity
um the capacity to maintain their own
Air Force so when we pulled our
contractors and essentially our
Mechanics for their Air Force rather
than having you know it's like
leader he you know he it's like you
teach a man to fish right you know
um that the minute we pulled those
mechanics out they didn't have an Air
Force anyway is that because in the
20-year training that we were training
militant like militants but not
engineers
well we were training the the arm I mean
I won't you know where'd you mouth but
we were training Armed Forces it wasn't
that wasn't I don't know mechanics
though I I was not I I was I I was in
ranger battalion I was not in charge of
understanding the relationship why
didn't you train them better Forest come
on man because they never taught me
please please it's very clear they never
taught me how to play everything we've
seen is forceful it's obvious
you have discovered what the Department
of State thinks yes exactly it's not our
policies it's the guy on the ground
yeah exactly yeah so but here's my
question here's my question his gas mask
cannot be properly fitted
here's my question to you Forrest yeah
could we have withdrawn in such a way
that Afghanistan would not have fallen
to the Taliban in three days
yeah yeah absolutely and that problem
would have started maybe 10 years ago
because we we didn't plan for when did
we start planning to pull out of
Afghanistan legitimately like how long
was it just an eventually thing we'll do
it right well we're gonna leave we have
to leave we have to figure out the terms
on which we're gonna leave maybe us we
we who are seen as the powers that be
the generals are like well we wouldn't
we are we're only going to willing to
pull out when it looks good when it
looks good for my political career
yeah that you think that's not a thing
like absolutely no no no well that's
what that's what uh you saw that thing
from Matt Zeller where he was on MSNBC
and he said that he told them over and
over again plan for this but they were
more concerned about looking bad than
actually solving you know planning for
the problem and now they look bad
because of it yeah plus you got guys who
and I'm sure you know this Dynamic well
it's hey we can't pull out now I got a
deployment coming up I just finished my
training we're all ready to go we're
about to do this you know I'm about to
make ranks so this is the last time this
is my my chance to be in the city in the
hot seat on deployment I'm not gonna
skip my deployment I'm going no yeah no
one wants to be a tabbed Ranger who went
overseas who never got to go over there
and that's to go home and visit his
family and run into his uncle who's
annoying as possible who was in in the
National Guard and he's got three
deployments
no that's a hundred percent true but
it's that mentality that drives a lot of
this decision making too I think it has
influence on it I don't I wouldn't
consider a root cause I think it has I
think I think it's a symptom not a cause
but but very simply
Joe Biden could have done this right
easily yeah what would he have done
different
in your opinion anyway for us I'm going
to build a foundation for this one first
this is going to be about a three minute
kind of piece let's do it but it's going
to require layers so if you're looking
at the the situation in Afghanistan
you're looking at multiple layers of
problems multiple layers of failures one
of them being this is going to piss off
a lot of people but generally speaking
Afghanistan is a failed state so it's
not a unified people it doesn't have a
Unified Government it's it's it's
constantly in a state of upheaval right
so if you're going to look at countries
like China America Russia Germany
Great Britain Mexico even
Afghanistan doesn't it did doesn't it
culturally does not have the unity that
even America has in our own fractured
nonsense right so for them as a culture
some of it is still very much so I'm I'm
really only loyal to My Tribe which
makes sense but they don't have the they
don't have the kind of trickling up
effect of of at least some sense of
loyalty or some sense of unified
cultural identity there are a lot of
spurious connections between them but
there's not a single unified cultural
identity in there some of this is
because of things that we just don't
understand in the west and some of them
are things that are a little bit more
nuanced than just tribalism but there
are issues within the Afghan culture
that which he saw because we spent 20
years and a lot well we spent all this
time and money building an American or
an Afghan military and as soon as they
saw the Taliban coming they're like ah
you know here's the guns we're good they
gave up the weapons so that's the first
layer the second layer
is that so much of the American
military's leadership was more concerned
about the opinions of people that don't
even like them or are actively working
against them they're so worried about
American News agencies writing hit
pieces on them because then their
political career is done because once
you get past a certain level in the
American Military on the officer scale
you become an inherently political
position and so the American Body
politics made this at this point it's it
you get that's that first I mean you
become an officer you're a politician
exactly well I don't even know what the
lieutenant looks like anymore but I
would expect something because if you're
going to be if you're going to put that
much investment into it you have to be
at least hoping to look far enough in
that you're going to go on for like a
kernel and move your way up there and
then the third part that comes into this
one is the American cultural issue of we
didn't as a culture
come to terms with what we were trying
to accomplish there nor did we as a
culture believe in our own values enough
to try to transpose them into this
country if we think certain things are
good like we're not even like
representative government as a value we
did not pass that on to the Afghan
people or they did not root it in they
did not take root of that so we were
talking about
Afghanistan is a multi-layered problem
you're dealing with bureaucrats making
Rules of Engagement
for the people who are on the ground
uh in in the words of a good friend of
mine you have people who are non-threats
that and what I mean by non-thread is
and they have no strategic value they
have no if if you if the if the an
opposing Force were to encounter them
they wouldn't even take them seriously
right so this person is so disconnected
from the American Military the concept
of War but somehow they're being allowed
to make Rules of Engagement for Navy
Seals Army Rangers Delta Force guys
where now you've got the guys who signed
the paper chose to do it and don't get
me wrong it's those people are
responsible too because they listen to
Bad leadership if they did when they did
if they did and then and it's not just a
blanket statement or the leadership is
bad because you're your own person
American rugged individualism begins at
the person and the American Military
gave that up as the American culture has
been giving that up so layer one
Afghanistan was never going to become a
glorious Utopia Layer Two the the more
concerned about what my American
constituents are going to say and then
Layer Three is on a cultural level we
gave up the fact fact that I as an
individual it's my responsibility if I'm
the one carrying the the firearm I am
the one who's responsible for it and
it's not that the people on the ground
gave that up it's that their political
leadership took that from them going
back to Nicholas Nicholas Nasim taleb if
you read
if you want to read three books of his
Black Swan anti-fragile skin in the game
skin in the game means if I'm not if I'm
the guy on the ground I know that I can
make decisions because I know that if
I'm looking at a combatant or
non-combatant I can make that decision
if my leadership does not believe that I
can make that decision but instead puts
Rules of Engagement which I don't even
get to engage that part of my mind
then they have failed the the the
apparatus that is the American concept
of War failed in Afghanistan which is no
surprise why China would be willing to
push it yeah this is also um covered in
the concept of the Strategic E4 right
the idea that when you look at some of
this stuff from a fourth generation
Warfare perspective the idea that Optics
are Warfare right so suddenly an E4 tip
of the spear right you're thinking oh
well I'm the bottom of this Echelon I
have this whole hierarchy above me keep
giving me the rules of order to making
these strategic decisions giving me
commander's intent but instead because
you're the one who's there and then
you've got someone on the other side
that's taking your picture or that's
portraying your actions or mis
portraying your actions right you are
now the face of U.S government policy
you're the face of the you know or in
their terms the way they would like to
portray it of course as the as the evil
Western occupying Empire that is
crushing their land for 20 years and
let's face it if you were you know if
you were someone in Afghan who's 18
years old right now right you don't know
what 9 11 was that's like something you
read about you know or maybe you saw a
video of but you just know that you've
been growing living in a country your
entire life as you've been growing up
and seeing foreign soldiers walking
around occupying your country telling
your government what to do and that
you've got some people saying oh just go
along with them even though they don't
speak your language they don't have your
values they don't share your religion
they don't share your culture and then
you've got another group that says no
follow us let's get rid of them let's
talk about the Rules of Engagement
though let's talk have you guys I'm
assuming you probably have experienced
things where it's like it makes no sense
absolutely absolutely absolutely you
know so yeah elaborate Forest Cooper
team leader 2013 was that was explained
that I have to tell my my uh the people
that I'm in charge of I'm a team leader
I'm in charge of guys I have to explain
to them that in the event there's a man
standing in his doorway with a belt-fed
machine gun shooting at your people uh
we are not allowed to return fire with
effective Weaponry because there's a a
possibility that somebody might be
standing behind him in his house what
yeah a bell-fed machine gun in his door
yep and so the appropriate response at
that time was to pull back to a safe
situation where you can contain it
without receiving effective fire okay
now we're using military jargon well you
can contain the situation without
receiving effective fire which is
anywhere between 50 yards and 300 yards
or whatever and then wait for him to
stop shooting
that's amazing
how
well I mean when they run out eventually
yeah okay so let's let's let's make
another very important distinction when
your job is you are in a special
operations unit and you're tasked with
performing things like a night raid
where you go we're gonna go after
perfect most famous night raid ever
going after Osama Bin Laden right so if
they had told the guys going after and
some Osama Bin Laden that you're not
allowed to shoot unless you're being
shot at
okay think about that Dynamic really
quickly yeah you're being employed by
the American Military to go after a
specific Target but you're supposed to
also act like you're A Beat cop in
Chicago and you're not allowed to
actually engage with the targets that
you know are armed and preparing to
fight against you until you have some
sort of check mark from somebody else
who has no skin in the game that
confirms that you have received
effective fire from somebody this is
really interesting we were looking at
this graph the other day that Lydia had
pulled up showing the different jobs by
political affiliation and it's like
you know Army Ranger probably tends to
be more conservative and then bureaucrat
who sets policy for armies RV Ranger
probably tends to be more liberal or or
something that effect you're going to
get people who don't do the job telling
you how to do the job dude they
commanded you to as a tactic a battle
Tech to his way for the enemy to stop
fighting that was your tactic that's a
great tactic that was also our strategy
it was yeah it wasn't a tactic it was
enforced by law if I broke that because
I was like oh well you know what I'm a
designated Marksman I know that I can
make this shot at this yardage and I
know that I I'm not being shot at right
now I am fully trained and confident in
that ability have the equipment and the
situation that presents it if I even
completed that then I would go home from
the mission and have to face lawyer well
not lawyer but I have to face an entire
effectively court appearance overseas by
Americans basically trying to figure out
whether or not they can throw me in is
this like does this happen where someone
will by the way you've got you've
probably got three or four activist jobs
eggs looking to make rank that look at
you and say aha we've got a situation
where somebody broke the rules they're
not looking at what your mission was or
what your objective was or what the
context of that particular objective was
they're looking at how can I make rank
as a Jag that's a military lawyer by
going after somebody Prosecuting them
yeah yeah and precisely so you could
save three people's lives and then they
would personally does that happen
completely wrong you didn't save their
lives you just failed to accidentally
hurt them right like if you like if
there was going to be a fire fight and
the guy with the machine gun was going
to mow down three of your guys and then
they were gonna mow him down but you
prevented that by sniping the guy how'd
you know he was gonna attack your people
yeah they're yeah right there's no way
to know he's he was opening fire with a
machine gun how do we know that he's
trying to hurt someone
um but what if he's got a machine gun
and he's like literally feeding the belt
in it while staring at you frantically
do people go through this court process
knowing that they save people's lives by
disobeying an order and they're like you
know what I did the right thing and then
they get their careers trashed and
they're thrown prison and yes they do
not care they do not care remember there
was even I mean it goes even further I'm
not this with um I don't know how much
we can talk about uh
the uh I don't even know how to say it
but the um basically there was a
situation where there would be underage
uh boys on on and around U.S military
bases and I'm trying to be very YouTube
friendly with this and we know and there
are specific terms for that I have no
idea whether YouTube has an issue with
the Afghani terms for that yeah probably
but just just not going to say it it's a
horrifying um but there would be times
where I'm sure you know these stories as
well where U.S soldiers would say I
can't take this anymore I can't live
with myself and they would step up and
try to stop it times where it was
happening where young boys are being
abused are being abused yes boys are
being abused but it was known about they
were told to shut up about it I mean the
New York Times has covered this
extensively
um this was being done by Afghan
Military Officers police officers and
even times where people lose their
careers get prosecuted before getting
involved with this and trying to stop it
right so you're trying to stop them so
not even talking about Rules of
Engagement which which obviously
completely separate thing this is just
you know right and wrong right kind of
stuff and they said well oh that's just
a cultural difference you you just you
know you have to let them is that what
we're trying to prop up you're you're a
company Commander you're in charge of
130 guys plus a couple of more and then
your company is attached to a Afghan
company
and you're supposed to be working with
each other they're well they're attached
to you fine
um and you haven't because you
understand that you need to integrate
your forces so that they can work well
together otherwise it's just going to be
too completely useless bodies on the
well one's going to be very useful and
one's going to be very lost
you can figure that out for yourself
um
uh land nav is not an officer specially
uh so but you can take this issue and
you're working with some of us can
recompass this
in 1970 oh so uh back to the joke
um uh you know I went to Ranger school I
know how that works uh but so in that
one you have and you're working with
you're working with a you have a host
nation cohort and you know they're
participating in not just casual
corruption like issues where it's not
just money being exchanged but many many
worse things and instead of being able
to say this is not the what we're going
to represent to our country We're Not
Gonna this because they're definitely
they're an inherently a reflection of on
you
you're the if the Americans protect the
people who do the bad things then they
are in part and parcel responsible for
it at least within the cultural concept
and so when you as a commander say we're
we're going to put a stop to this in
this connected force and you get
sidelined because it wasn't politically
operative or optimal that's what you're
dealing with right yep
man
ramifications of that you talk about the
22 veteran suicide the day that
obviously this is something that's
driving
um you know and and you're right by the
way that's that is the different
cultural values it is a very Western
cultural value that if you see some like
see something say something how many
times do we say that right but that's
not the same in all cultures right in
other cultures they'll say well I don't
know that person and I'm not involved in
that so why should I get involved we
would encounter Villages towns and areas
where a person would be targeted we
would our person would be targeted
because he was
100 confirmed being a bomb manufacturer
intended to do harm on whoever right he
he there and and there and they have
their little compound with their walls
and they in that compound they're
building explosives for the purpose of
maiming and killing American soldiers
and Afghan citizens their neighbor will
know about it and say it's not on my
property so I don't care correct it's I
do not care that my neighbor
oh yeah yeah my neighbor and well that's
one Dynamic right they'll be like oh
yeah my neighbor works for the Taliban
he builds bombs and you're like thanks
but then you then you also ought to deal
with the secondary layer of you and I
are neighbors you're the American
government and you and I are in a feud
and I'll be like
you know I want some of his land uh but
I won't tell you that I'll be like yeah
he builds bombs and so you right so it's
that's like that's like the Soviet Union
now my friends who are who who are from
there have said similar stories where
you know I was hanging out an apartment
and my friend told me that she's like
hey you know the apartment next to this
one
you know back in the during the Soviet
Union there were two neighbors and they
were feuding with each other so the
person who lived here just called the
Communist party and said they were
bad-mouthing the party and the day later
their apartment was empty nope
it's a nightmarish way to live man
we're screwed up because you're talking
about values he talked about an American
value at least a western value is this
idea that we know our neighbors and we
at least hold them to a certain level of
accountability to some extent at least I
mean that might yeah like if you're in
the U.S right and I see my next door
neighbor like like beating their dog or
something or you know their kid or
whatever it is like you're gonna call
the cops most likely yeah you were going
I mean nine times out of ten someone in
the U.S is gonna say all right I'm gonna
pick up the phone and do something about
that because that's wrong right I see
those wrong other parts of the world
it's hey that's their dog that's their
kid maybe they did something wrong
uh yeah and there's a left and right
limit to that for sure sure because then
you run into you know the uh then you
run into the Minneapolis problem well
they didn't have a black lives matter
flag outside their house so let's burn
it down next well you've seen like the
riots in in Hamburg during I think it
was the G20 or whatever all the windows
are smashed out except for one it's a
photo all the windows smash tags are for
one and it's got the Communist fist in
the window that's the one that gets that
gets it gets left alone but I I I've
been studying a lot of like War history
and a lot of times it's like you know
the army goes into the city they they
kill most of the male Fighters and then
they rape the women and pillage and burn
the city this doesn't always happen but
it was pretty pretty frequent like
normal the commander would be like okay
he lets his troops pillage because if he
doesn't they're going to Mutiny and kill
him so he lets his troops but we've like
gone the opposite direction with like
the Geneva Convention and the American
Military Prime proper like taking make
sure you don't upset your your foes
before you kill them
um and I wonder if we've gone too far
like War the the one that tries to fight
with with honor is the one that loses I
mean that's we learned that in the
revolution solutionary War you see that
world war one I'm not I wouldn't be so
cynical as not willing to fight with
honor I think that's a bit of a hyper
simplification okay you're definitely so
an example of where of where your
example an example of what your uh your
uh
metaphor your example does come out is
so you go into an Afghan town you kick
down a door and you and and and you find
the character that you're looking for
now you have to pay the family the
American equivalent of the fanciest door
to the family because you kicked on the
door because could you have done it
without kicking down the door like dude
he's a terrorist why do I have to pay
the family for the door well because you
did damage to the property like we were
going after him because he was
facilitating insert one of these issues
he was doing one of these things like we
didn't just go after him willy-nilly
because his name is whatever it's you
know you go after a guy he's building
bombs he's facilitating Fighters he's in
he's he's he's he's he's he's uh
recruiting recruiting he's whatever I
mean you could figure out any of the
answer why so so you go into the The
Village you you have your target
structure you hit the building
and then afterwards you're like well now
we have to pay the family for the door
American police don't if they kick a
door down they don't pay for the door oh
American citizens would you look at that
American police and military differences
there's a lot of big ethical and moral
questions that arise from what's going
on in Afghanistan and the first is you
know you mentioned the horrible things
that they do they have this really
disgusting practice that we can't really
talk about on YouTube but it's child
abuse and and actually that that's one
of the things just to get into the more
complexity of it that's one of the
things that the Taliban was against and
so one of the ways that they originally
in Omar and Kandahar were raising were
rising to power was because they were
were essentially they would find out
about stuff like that going on and then
execute people in the streets and so
people would say they were so sick of it
they'd say okay well uh let's go for
this extreme reaction let's let's join
in with these guys because at least
they'll do something about it but so I I
think about the us being in this foreign
land where a bunch of people don't like
them as you pointed out they don't speak
the language they don't even look like
you they're a bunch of Imperial powerful
Troopers who come in and tell you how to
live and what you have to do and there
were people who were there who are like
no way they were going to resist by any
means necessary the problem I see is I
don't think we should have been there if
we wanted to go after Al Qaeda that I
understand sticking around for a nation
building and occupying this country
results in people resisting you and for
all of the really horrifying things I
would personally wish they were not
doing I don't know if that is
justification for the us being the World
Police for every single issue like that
because if we were going to go into
every country where they had a problem
like that we'd be occupying the you know
uh North Africa for for everything
that's happening like with the slaves
right now I could sit here for hours and
tell you about you know after country
that's that's conducting we can't do
moral atrocity yeah there's always going
to be a Rwanda out there if we're gonna
go after somebody though we better go
after him that's the issue that I have
this is what this is where I come from
the on the ground guy right exactly so
it's like again if you've trained guys
who spend millions of dollars to train
dudes to be really really good at what
they're doing were the American when
this was the initial the the initial
operations in Afghanistan October 2011
was just that
look at those kind of things right like
look at the the abilities of the of the
American Warfighter uh jawbreaker right
I don't remember because if it was if
we're talking about like 2001 it's like
jawbreaker Anaconda like some of those
really early and I was really young of
course of course um and and I will not
pretend to be the most astute historian
in American military history
um because as especially when you look
at the global war Ontario it gets bigger
the more you look into it oh yeah but a
very simple answer is you let the people
who you've trained to do the job do the
job
you let you you don't you do not put
artificial inhibitation artificial
barriers for them so when we're talking
about Navy Seals Army Rangers Delta
Force uh Special Forces guys it's like
okay
what's the mission dismantle the
taliban's network in this area okay go
do that and go do that to the best of
your ability and just keep doing that
until you've accomplished the the
dissolution of the Taliban network no we
don't really want to go after the
Taliban Network anymore now we want to
engage in nation building because it
looks better for our constituents I got
a question about Afghanistan did you uh
when when when the U.S went in did they
set up a bunch of checkpoints requiring
an identification from the citizenry
not eventually eventually yeah they had
to I mean a checkpoint is an a
checkpoint is also a method of area
denial it's not as simple as saying well
we're here for papers please it's a it's
a it is a way to a checkpoint is it is
an uncomfortable way of saying it's
going to get people's attention and so
we can observe people we basically are
it's a it's a third it's a third
Honeypot it's a third order movement
right so if I put a checkpoint out here
I can also watch how people move around
that checkpoint or maybe if that
checkpoint is so that they can't come
into the embassy that's pretty straight
but I'm going for a Segway here so did
you ever force people if they want was
there ever a policy where it was like
people could not freely use Services
anywhere during this these operations
unless they had ID to prove who they
were or what you know what they were
doing I think I receive where this is
going oh you see where this is going
yeah yeah I'm making a point about
military occupation versus what we're
seeing in our country right now yeah
that was two special checkpoints you
were right I said house two special for
checkpoints
that's an inflated ego conversation I
think I think what we could say though
is that there was a lot certainly a lot
of vetting that went on for people that
were in these uh these joint units
people who were allowed to join the Ana
uh also people who served as contractors
um uh of host nation uh Nationals that
were serving on bases there's a ton of
vetting that went into this there were
Biometrics that were were conducted and
that even with all of this vetting that
was done you still had a massive amount
of what were called Green on Blue
attacks and you cannot talk about
resettling Afghanistan refugees in quote
unquote refugees in the United States
without confronting that very real fact
that even the people who were vetted and
many times this is we're talking about
extreme vetting right yeah we're still
connect these green and blue attacks
yeah what's a green on Blue so green on
Blue attack means you know so blue
forces is like me and my allies that's
my buddies red forces that's the bad guy
that's uh that's that's the enemy right
but green is the sort of you know you're
a host nation uh National your host
country National or you know you're so
you're someone who's working for us in a
in a contractor capacity during civilian
capacity you're not but you're not you
know one of our one of our allies in in
uniform right
um I knew a guy who got you know the
dfac who got shot in the in the
cafeteria as he was waiting in line to
get ciao one day right by by someone who
was working there just got shot in the
stomach wow
for the knuckle draggers out there like
me in that sense uh well okay so for
that since a green on blue green is
Afghan in this scenario green was the
Afghan military and then blue is
American right sometimes it was
accidental sometimes it was not
accidental
man so well so so the the point I was
trying to get to was I was trying to be
rather disparaging of of New York
considering we were talking about war
and all that and hearing about you know
just these the things that you were able
to not able to do and then I think about
what's happening in our own country and
it kind of feels like it's beyond
occupation right you know so my question
was General not that you ever operated a
checkpoint or there were checkpoints
right and and by the time I was I was
more involved by the time I spent more
time in Kabul most of those checkpoints
within the city were run by Afghan
Nationals which had there was there
there was easily examples of layers of
corruption there bribes Beyond reason I
mean it doesn't matter but there were
checkpoints within major cities
and there are also checkpoints
um between certain political standpoints
actually my my one jstock buddy always
has this great line about that it's it's
quick I know you want to segue but you
got to hear this one so it because it
talks about the moral differences right
so he would say in the United States we
consider it corrupt if you are a
government official and you give jobs to
your family in Afghanistan you are
considered corrupt if you're a
government official and you don't give
jobs to your family
so now what we have here in the U.S in
uh in New York is substantially worse
than any kind of checkpoint or
uh you know I guess General search in a
designated area we have you can't enter
buildings and then that would happen
without an ID all right so I uh actually
uh you I don't know if you guys saw I
was on Fox news earlier and for those
listening on the watching the clip
they'll probably they'll probably put a
clip above it
um because I did you know as I've been
mentioning for the past couple of days I
did a bunch of phone calls I called the
city and what's happening in New York is
substantially worse than a military
occupation that you you have to fire
your employees if they have a disability
borrowing them from vaccination you you
want to enter any building you got to
have an ID a company must terminate
their employees and so I'm thinking
about this stuff I'm like how did we get
to the point where New York has
basically violated civil rights law
across the board from the federal
government without and how does this
happen how does it happen that in our
own cities you know you you can't even
you can't even shoot at a guy if he's
got a machine gun pointed at you but in
New York they can straight up say the
Ada is in the toilet we can do whatever
we want
it's a million times well there's a lot
there's a lot worse with actual military
conflict but I tell you man the Nazis
they went after the disabled first and
now we're at the point where watching
this in Four Seasons you've got La SF
New Orleans and New York under these
lockdowns you are getting to a situation
in the United States where it's it's
really amazing and you could get into
the moral and ideological implications
of of why this is but it is a medical
part it is Medical Apartheid uh you are
having people that are being told
because of their personal decisions or
their personal medical history that they
are no longer allowed to participate in
society and those same people are also
if you watch certain other media a lot
of mainstream media now they are being
demonized they are being authorized they
are being labeled and they are being
more and more when I say demonized I
really mean that because the the
president United States just gave a
speech today Joe Biden gave a speech
today talking about how it's the
unvaccinated fault that all this is
going on it is your fault you are the
ones that you're the reason that this
pandemic is still going on you need to
do this we need to push this in those
governors that are standing in the way
of masks they're standing in the way of
mandates they need to stop and they need
to get with the program you know you
know what I like that everyone seems to
be using now anathematize
what's that mean uh it's like a a
condemnation from the cathedral like an
official curse or condemnation from The
Authority so that's what we're seeing
the I guess what the word be the
anathematization there you go of groups
of groups of people be it because they
have personal medical issues that aren't
necessarily disabilities but they have
to make some hard choices or because
they have just personal choice and by
all means I I'm sure that people can
argue you want to make an argument and
say well your personal choice is bad for
us I don't choose to drive drunk I'm
like okay that's not the same argument
but I'll tell you this what about
somebody who goes to the doctor and the
doctor says no and now
when you go to these restaurants what
happens they say I'm sorry you're fired
because of your disability well it's not
it's not I don't want to make it seem
like nobody's fighting back because we
do have an article from over at
timcast.com restaurants Sue Mayor Bill
de Blasio over vaccine passport mandate
a group of restaurants and businesses in
New York City have filed a lawsuit
against Mayor Bill de Blasio over the
vaccine passport and this is interesting
they mentioned there is no
um there's no medical exemptions there's
exemptions for celebrities performers
yeah that's right if you book a show you
don't got to be a celebrity book a show
you're good don't worry about it we
don't we don't we don't we don't need
that from you the New York Post reports
and the lawsuit filed on Tuesday in
Staten Island Supreme Court the
businesses argued the Mandate violates
their constitutional rights and unfairly
targets certain establishments because
churches grocery stores schools offices
and medical facilities do not have the
same strict requirement Additionally the
Mandate does not make any allowances for
people who cannot get the vaccine or
already have antibodies from having the
virus it makes no except option for
people allergic to the ingredients in
the vaccines have religious beliefs
against them or have pre-existing
conditions
so uh one of our friends made a phone
call
and asked a restaurant if they would bar
someone with a disability from coming in
as you guys know I talked about how I
made this phone call and they said
I'm sorry regardless if you don't have
the vaccine you can't come in and he
said uh what about a Jewish person would
you would you let them in and they said
what do you mean like if they were
instructed you know because of their
religious beliefs they couldn't and
they're like oh absolutely not they
wouldn't be allowed in the establishment
the religious beliefs do not give you
any kind of exemption from from this
well and by the way you know as
um you know as the uh the category token
Catholic on the on the podcast and since
no shim cast tonight but
um and really just for Christians as
well though that they that so in in the
Catholic faith in the Christian faith
abortion is obviously something that's
completely against our religion it is I
mean it is throughout the Bible etc etc
not to get all that but it is a hundred
percent against
a lot of the vaccines used aborted
fetuses in their development and so a
lot of people have looked at that in
good faith and say look this is this is
just against my religious beliefs to use
something that benefited and was created
through abortion that this is something
that is completely against our religious
beliefs it's something that we believe
in our core and it's something that we
completely reject and it goes deeper too
because you're using the term anathema
and that term has a long history I mean
being Catholic I would figure the
history of the term anathema to be
cutting you off from the source of
Salvation right so the idea is if you're
anathema I am being able to whether it
whether so I'm not Catholic I'm reformed
um but uh I'm and in that sense we may
have different beliefs but the the
concept Remains the Same it is as if
somebody were to say you are no longer
or you are not saved we are cut off from
the grace of Christ
so that's a heavy thing to say and
you're paralyzed you're you're parallel
to it though is very important here
because you're also now dealing in major
cultural differences that we're starting
to see on the metaphysics level we
believe in a difference between positive
and negative rights so a negative right
is such that I cannot impose on
something to you I cannot it is a it is
befouling your rights it is if it is I
have I have a great way to explain
positive negative rights good a negative
right to life means I can't kill someone
a positive right to life means I'm
obligated to try and save you if I see
you dying yes and we don't believe in
the same positive rights as in I don't
have to go out of my way to prevent you
from
something right but what you're seeing
especially in this example is that
people are viewing the
conscious decision not to get the
vaccine as in as a violation of somebody
else's negative rights you're seeing
this in the last but but this is nothing
new this is nothing new we've been
seeing it on the colleges for years you
know silence is violence it's all the
same thing you know people were saying
for the longest time once these college
kids get out of school into the real
world and I said it how many times I
probably said it 500 times over the past
couple of years yeah once these kids get
into the real world I however I want to
be fair to myself and say I've always I
still have always had but maybe what
happens is they graduate college and get
jobs here and the companies just do what
they want I guess right yeah they do
they get jobs in HR and then they
control your company and they'll tell
you who that you can and cannot hire
based on race and gender and and because
or whatever ibrahamex candy says today
well I wasn't I wasn't actually going to
go into this but you just gave us a good
way to put in it put it out that when
you said it is your connection from
the source of Grace right that is
anathema well that is what they see
themselves as doing right right so these
government leaders political leaders
establishment leaders they view the
power of government and good society as
being on the side of Grace as but that's
why the term Cathedral is used so often
right it's because we are on the side of
the Angels this our Progressive World
sphere and our control over this part of
society is Grace and there is nothing
higher right because they're
materialistic even so this is it even
though if you have broken one of our
social Commandments then we must cut you
off are you saying but it's materialism
as well it's it's straight up it's not
even the metaphysical it's not even the
grace it's literally like the you want
to use our banks it's almost better
here's another way of dividing that
question yeah are you saying that it's
it's the are you saying that
um the issue with their belief system is
that they believe it or is it the belief
system itself they view this is
again I'm going to actually tie this
into a similarity between something like
Russian communism the government is God
the government is Holy they got
everything the government says it's like
a great example would be the first
episode of that HBO miniseries on
Chernobyl while the government just said
it couldn't happen so it's not happening
like they believed themselves as the
author and dictator of reality right
that's how so convoluted they got now
you're looking at early stage issues
with that where they is are you saying
that the problem that you have with
their belief system is that they believe
it's so holy they believe in the
Holiness of the state so well or is it
is it the fact that they believe it
itself or is it the belief is it what
they believe or that they believe it
because I would say something like I
believe that
I insert some easy one I believe that
murder is wrong okay so and I believe
that with absolute conviction that for
me to just go murder out of greed or
whatever is wrong
okay so I believe that with absolute
conviction
am I wrong because I believe it or is my
belief wrong so is there belief in the
uh the cathedral the the the the new
Inquisition non-catholic church but the
new inquisition of the state
as being holy
is that's I think that's where it's
wrong that they view themselves wrong
well no it's not both wrong because I
can't fault them for believing something
but I can say that their belief is wrong
yeah they believe that the government is
telling them the truth they believe in
the power of the system what they
believe is kind of all changes by the
day depending on what the CDC comes out
with the state is what they want the CC
the CCP believes in their
accomplishments and and right they
believe and believe it was given to them
by heaven or whatever do they though do
they really I don't know I mean maybe
maybe not but they believe it and so we
can't fault people for believing things
let's put it this way alone it's it's
not just the belief it's the enforcement
that's the issue right right the issue
is the enforcement of the belief if
there is somebody out there that you
know praises the national register and
you see these people who actually have
little like shrines to Dr fauci in their
homes while they call Trump supporters a
cult
um and they're singing you know Broadway
musicals that they've changed the words
out and put in with Dr fauci
that they are quite literally they are
quite literally
um making him as an avatar of government
an idol right they are idolizing
government and so they are making
government in this case the state and
writ large the overstate would you if
you combine Academia and some elements
of the corporate sphere in this that
they are then enforcing that through
what you just said in New York they're
cultural institutions now the cultural
institutions are enforcing that belief
on everybody and that's the issue I I
have this tweet from political math on
Twitter polymath it's a clip from
Stephen uh Colbert's show where he
Likens Trump voters to the Taliban oh
yeah totally yeah and polymath says
there are two options this is a
rhetorical game and people like Colbert
are so frightened by reality that they
Retreat to this harmless rhetorical
rhetorical marshmallow Happy Land where
nothing means anything or two they're
serious and they think we should kill
Trump supporters that's that's a
horrified Prospect I think it's
somewhere in between
um I think it's also the idea that with
what we're saying right now right they
have this belief system they have this
belief system in the power of this the
not just the power of the state but the
grace of the state the grace of the
overstates and so the Taliban refuses to
believe in the grace of the state Trump
supporters refuse to believe in the
grace of the states but it's you know
it's like one of those logic equations
where that that doesn't mean that they
believe the same things as this house
equivalency it's a false equivalence
yeah you know I have a I have a Twitter
thread I'd like to pull up and uh show
y'all guys something uh Whenever there
is an apocalyptic news cycle I always
start the Tweet with I don't want to set
the world on fire I just want to start a
flame in your heart which of course is a
Fallout reference for those that are
fans and it's just uh the imagery of
that song playing for those that are
familiar with Fallout 3 is that you see
DC in a wasteland it's a nuclear
Wasteland and it's playing this old song
from I think the 50s or something like
that and that's why I write it and I've
pulled up let's see we got here we got
four we got eight we got uh the entire
playlist right here there you go I've
got six
articles I pulled up about supply chain
collapse and the reason I pulled this up
is because there's a big story about
Nando's food it's a Nando's shortage 50
restaurants were shut down in the UK
because of a chicken shortage so I've
been tracking the food shortage story
for some time
and also the food inflation story and
the one thing I've said over and over
again is that for some reason the
mainstream news cycle is not talking
about the food shortage of which there
is one and maybe for the most part you
don't notice because a shortage of of
food in certain areas just means you eat
something else because we still have a
lot of food or also it could just mean
you're paying more and slowly starting
to notice maybe you see Joe Biden
increase food benefits because prices
are going up that also happens and the
reason I bring this up is after I showed
these 16 articles saying things like
Nando's closest 45 restaurants Rogue
Valley restaurants facing food shortage
Burger King Popeyes say labor shortage
and and food shortages are causing
prices to increase understaffed Colorado
restaurants so it's not just food it's
also labor I then show this the one
thing you know I love to cite
particularly over the past week how
would you rate the condition of the
national economy right now Democratic
voters say 57 fairly good I did a Google
search for food shortage and it's page
after page after page all in the last
week of all these localities saying we
have shortages of this that or otherwise
Chinese food restaurants across the
country have been they've been reporting
it in various jurisdictions but because
CNN doesn't say it
it must not exist and that is the
cathedral the religion these people
follow how in how could anyone who
watches the news legitimate news with a
critical mind believe the economy is
going well we had 4 million resignations
in April they're calling it The Great
resignation they say more are coming
they say oh but look we added 950 000 or
so jobs this past month but we also have
10 million a record job openings because
people are quitting more people are
quitting we may be adding jobs people
are quitting
you've got a food shortage you've got
Nando's shutting down and yet you still
have people look at this here's the best
part
during uh Donald Trump I think it's fair
to say the the Democrats believe the
economy was pretty good during Donald
Trump even though they didn't like the
guy I can respect that they believed
that it was fairly good not very good
but then something happened the
coronavirus stock market crash and there
was an inversion all of a sudden now the
Democrats felt everything was bad
and do you know what date it was
January 20th that that started to flip
what a great January January 20th good
guess good guess the moment Joe bides
Joe Biden gets elected
it was a little dip after election day
but after Joe Biden is inaugurated the
the Democrats who felt the economy was
very bad plummeted and the Democrats who
felt the economy was good skyrocketed
simply by virtue of having a different
president all of a sudden the economy
was good I gotta say I don't think any
of those numbers have any value it
sounds like they're just voting whether
or not they like the president exactly
but think about what that means when you
look at independent voters and
Republican voters they track more like
this with the true but this also goes
back to what we were just saying when
you view your
theological belief as through the lens
of the state so you believe in the grace
of the state I want to tease this out a
little bit more then the leader of the
state right is now also the leader of
your religion yeah right and he
approaches all of you so it preaches to
you right so if you're if you're you
know pope all of a sudden becomes Donald
Trump and you're in a vowed liberal
Democrat right this kind of explains
some of the reaction that you got to
that right this where it was a a
visceral emotional experience that they
had when he was elected versus a lot of
people who looked at it and said oh you
know what yeah I I didn't vote that way
I guess we'll have somebody else in the
office for a term I'd have to imagine it
must be like being Catholic and saying
the the devil literally rise from the
ground you'd be you'd be freaking out
yes yeah well the conservatives view a
separation of church and state as in I
recognize that I have my religion and
then I have well maybe not all this is a
gross exagger operation but there's the
idea of the separation of church and
state can collapse in two different
directions you can either have the
church become the state and eat the
state where you saw a lot of the
conflicts in the Medieval ages as
they're prescribed by non-literate
historians and then you have the
Communist example where they dissolve
the church and take on its authorities
what is the difference between the
church and the state the state is the
sword the church is the pulpit so the
church tells you what is right but does
not have the ability to enforce it with
a sword the state has the sword but does
not have the ability to dictate to you
what is right because the state the
sword is only there to to
honor contracts and protect rights not
dictate morality so if I go to a pastor
and a pastor says tithe or
um don't cheat on your wife or some sort
of positive thing like you know what if
you need if you want to do some good
here's a here's some charity you can
participate in that's different than the
state coming to you and saying uh we're
you're going to do what we tell you is
good or we'll use the sword against you
and then and so you're talking about
this this Pope nature yeah these people
don't believe that the economy is bad
because their savior is in uh is is
there
like it's it's because Joe Biden's but
but even even when Trump was president
before kovid there was still it was over
60 percent in uh uh oh I'm sorry that
was Obama when when uh yeah hold on hold
on sorry I'm looking at one part sorry
from from I guess I'm confused all the
time from the 60 down to 40 before covet
so it's between 40 and 60 of Democrats
felt the economy was fairly good under
Donald Trump I mean 40 is still pretty
high right right I prefer that I don't
want to make it seem like right you know
under Obama it was like 65 thought the
economy was very good Donald Trump got
elected there was a little drop off
which is kind of hilarious but a little
one and it stayed around 60 for a little
bit for a little bit and then went down
to 50 about you know a year later and
then down to 40 and then covet happened
it hits the bottom and then biting its
elect then it goes right back up so for
using this as a measure of Statistics
it's a set of facts not evaluations how
would we evaluate the decisions the
people who what are we trying to
evaluate here are we trying to evaluate
the opinion the the
validity of the opinions of the people
who changed their opinion on the economy
based on well let me let me let me put
it this way if uh if I said to an
independent or a republican do you think
it is going to rain they would look up
at the sky and say you know that does
look like a storm cloud I think it might
rain I would give it a 30 chance so you
get 100 you know Independents and 100
Republicans and you ask them and they'll
give you relatively similar answers the
independence lean more towards more
optimistic it's probably going to be a
little Sunny it'll clear up but they all
look and then you get about 40 I think I
think actually the um the plurality of
negative is like 68 to 70 percent of
Independents and Republicans believe the
economy is bad so they're all looking up
and they're going that's that's a storm
cloud it's probably going to rain and
some are like I don't know I think it'll
clear and then you ask Democrats and
instead of looking up at the sky they
look down at their phones and then they
scroll through Twitter and they say no
rain better check CNN oh nope CNN says
CNN says it's not raining so it's not
raining and you're like but there's a
cloud in the sky yes yeah so the
governor of Minnesota is Governor walls
also colloquially known as Lord walls
declass
yeah it's great Lord walls declares that
today no one shall be doing indoor
dining that's what de Blasio is doing
yes that's exactly the same although
yeah Wilhelm is demanding your papers
that's his name what's his name Warren
Wilhelm his original name yeah
what did Kaiser mean
would it sound too cool to call de
Blasio Kaiser Wilhelm no we should
definitely do that 100 carrying it back
Kaiser yes Kaiser we will uh absolutely
show our papers you know the thing about
New York is you need your ID to get in
let alone the vaccine passport no ID
sorry so that's what that's like 70 of
the black community in New York can't go
inside buildings anymore but you know
what you know what you know what
Honestly though I'm willing to bet up in
like the Bronx and Harlem they're not
checking
what are they going to do they don't
have the means to do it like what I mean
by that is like if I'm going into a like
a corner store or like a bodega or
something are they really gonna sit
there and I don't think you need it for
that not not for that but like a
sit-down restaurant but that could be
Taco Bell what about a standard you're
allowed to walk into a restaurant for
takeout so your takeout's fine right so
what I mean is by the means is that
these restaurants have to hire someone
to sit at the door and do vaccine checks
now so like when you're carting someone
at a bar yeah and so the most most of
the places that have the ability to do
this are like in Manhattan they're not
in central Brooklyn or you know uh South
Brooklyn or uh it's not Flatbush Avenue
yeah yeah I mean probably in the Hipster
areas do you where it's do you want to
go into business with me I want to start
a business where we just vaccine check
and we only take bribes
yes this sounds lucrative actually you
know Afghanistan you are vaccinated you
might want to regret that because I'm
willing to bet a company will pop up in
New York right now that says we we do
vaccine checks and they contract to all
the businesses and then right they could
easily have 30 000 employees in a week
I'm looking forward to the the the black
market that's going to rise up like the
the prohibition market like we saw with
alcohol the the speakers restaurants and
basements yes all the the groups
organizations of speakeasies that are
going to now it's gonna be a genre it's
going to be an industry as good right
yeah dude prop uh it did so much damage
to the American people and and the
economy and everything trying to
prohibit alcohol like haven't we learned
our lesson we see what prohibiting weed
has done to society I want to talk about
group psychosis you remove the weed and
make people feel bad for it so you want
you want to here's the Silver Lining to
that so today is the 18th of August 2021
today's the last day for comment on the
atf's attempt to redefine what a
receiver is for a firearm they're trying
to go after 80 lowers involved today's
the last day to comment on this so if
you haven't please do
um and you can find more of that on
recoilweb.com if you have to Shameless
plug uh but here's the here's the here's
the Silver Lining we just want we just
watched the American government so great
and powerful that it be uh accidentally
lose a bunch of belt-fed machine guns
night vision equipment silence so that
silencer suppressors rifles two and a
[ __ ] helicopters did the Taliban have to
pay a class 3 tax yeah you know on any
NFA right you know regularly going after
them for decades but so like so so
here's the salute part of that solution
in the Silver Lining is stop taking the
clown seriously right so when when
um when David Chipman they're trying to
appoint David Chipman as the head of the
ATF he's that Mass child murderer isn't
he
he was a participant in Waco
so yes and children were murdered at
Waco yep there you go yes I also don't
want him to show up at my house tomorrow
oh okay by the way not only unrepentant
uh he's he a celebratory participant
yeah I mean okay he went on Reddit he's
going on Reddit and and defended it to
the hilt to the hilt about Waco not even
not even a question of you know oh my
gosh I wish it hadn't gone that way but
you know we had our the situation
situation straight up lied about the
people actually you were telling us a
good story before we went on it's not
exactly a story but it's a really
spurious connection of events so that's
what he did it's what he said yeah right
so uh will you shot a firearm the first
time I came out here we shot one of your
Firearms it was a Beretta M82 barrett
Barrett I'm sorry yeah Barrett M82 50
caliber semi-automatic I know I'm
supposed to get my numbers right what's
the name right those are words uh so we
shot a Barrett M82 and the origin a
friend of mine who's a gunsmith this
week informed me on the origins of the
Barrett M82 so back in the days when the
mujadin were fighting against the
Russians the Americans created the
Barrett M82 to use a common
anti-vehicular round that was that had
been around for a while which was the 50
caliber round and they put into a sniper
rifle that was semi-automatic so you
have to pull the trigger and then pull
the trigger again so it's no fully
automatic every you have to pull the
trigger to shoot you around
and the advantage of that firearm was
that it could be used to take out
certain Russian helicopters that were by
plaguing Afghanistan
so that kind of gets ingrained in the
cultural history of the firearm and then
a couple of years later a decade and a
year later
there's Waco
and what happens at Waco supposedly
according to David Chipman somebody shot
down a helicopter with a plane with a
sniper rifle which would have been a
Barrett and he all he's got to say is
they had a Barrett so they shot down a
helicopter and he can go in front of the
American people digitally and in voice
outright lie to them
that people at Waco shot down a plane
with a Barrett 50 cal this is what he
just had on Reddit this is exactly he
went on Reddit and was making this
argument yeah yeah it's not completely
not just how did the helicopter get shot
down there was there was a helicopter
that crashed if I'm not mistaken but it
was not related to it yeah my
understanding is it didn't happen yeah
it just no it completely didn't happen
but what your point is that was that he
was using this sort of cultural history
yep of the American weapons platform in
order to basically
you know not not even deduce but just
sort of like I'm gonna connect
manipulate the narrative so that people
would think that this helicopter had
been shot down by them simply because
they had a certain weapons platform or
he could even say well they must have
wanted to shoot down helicopters because
what else would you use a Barrett for
was it confirm that they had a Barrett I
I wouldn't even be able to tell you but
I I so if he were to come here the
information to the cast castle and find
out that that Mr uh Mr Timothy Poole
owns a Barrett then he would say oh well
you must be shooting at helicopters
aren't you it's the only thing you can
mm-hmm
well shall we go to super chats my
friends if you haven't already please
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and go to timcast.com become a member
because we're going to have the members
only segment coming up around 11 or so
p.m but let's read Wi-Fi 117 says what's
China you mean East Taiwan no we mean
West West Taiwan yeah
all right
George
Georgio oh George Giorgio sorry Tim with
the fall of Afghanistan the Chinese
Communist Party would make their move on
Taiwan after the 2022 Beijing Winter
Olympics
do you guys agree no you don't think so
no I don't think so no
for reasons I outlined earlier I
actually bet somebody a thousand dollars
this week that China will not invade
Taiwan in the next 90 days
I'm going to get that thousand dollars
all right Shock Trooper 333 says hey Tim
missed you yesterday was busy I was
deployed to Bagram Airfield for the end
of the Evac ofs operation freedoms
Sentinel Trump's Evac plan in Bagram was
simple all contractors were airlifted
out months before we did so this um by
the way this and so I want people to
know this
um uh shout out to my friend Raheem
Kasam who had a huge scoop today
National polls that back in June the
state department actually canceled
Trump's Evac plan for Afghanistan that
they had put in place this was something
they had done prior to uh obviously the
election
um he had all the documents on this Free
Beacon came out and said they eventually
were able to confirm the whole thing too
so massive massive story huge Scandal by
the way because then you've got you know
Austin and Millie Millie who by the way
is considering you know possibly putting
in for retirement after at you know with
maybe like uh say a month post Evac once
this is all cleaned up they just
realized that you saw that press
conference today they looked like a deer
in the headlights of realizing that so
you've been checkmated by the Taliban
right basically it's like it's like
you're playing chess and you just like
play to lose and then the kid on the
other side says okay well I'll just do
this this and this and boom there you go
now what now what move are you in and no
consequences none no whatsoever it
doesn't matter you're the guy you're
you're the guy on the ground you have
all the consequences it's your fault
yeah the guy in the chair the guy
getting shot at yeah that has to make
split decisions right and and and has to
deal with you know you you go into a
building under night vision and you're
suddenly faced with a crying child and a
woman and then and you but you know
there's a guy that just ran into that
room with a gun and you're the one
making the decision and so yeah so so
what was it they in in the long long
before time they would when there was a
problem in the village they would take a
goat and put on the field and say the
goat did it is that what it was yeah is
that where it comes from yeah so it's
always you're the guy hey don't look at
me I just I just told you what to do and
how to do it and that guy signed the
paper is you're the one who did it so
right all right we got important one
here Robert Poynter says hey Tim James
Lindsey just put on an article where he
discusses the Tim pool Gap put this to
bed which is the chicken and which is
the Egg of wokeness culture or Academia
um it's hard to understand what you mean
by culture or Academia I will say
Academia is not the progenitor of
woteness in my opinion I do believe it
is a contributing factor but let me
explain critical race theory has been
around for a long time critical race to
your ideas have been around but been
around for a long time and there's a
reason that I on this show draw a
distinction between critical race Theory
and wokeness because wokeness
encompasses a whole bunch of other
things notably that Democrats think the
economy is good there is this weird cult
now critical race Theory became a
component critical race applied
principles became a component because
certain people who followed these things
saw what they could exploit and latch
onto so I'll put it this way
wokeness is the giant Beast flying
around yeah it's the dragon and Academia
and these academics are basically small
little parasites that jumped on its back
and are now slowly crawling to its brain
to try and control the Beast and guide
it in a certain direction so the
argument was um because I was talking
with James Lindsay Helen pluckrose and
Peter pagosian they were the they're the
people who pull off the so-called
squared hoax where they hoax these
academic journals I love that thing
that's so funny Peter pagosian was
adamant it started in Academia I was
adamant to that it started because of
algorithm algorithms and before Facebook
and these woke blogs and ragebait and
before the social media manipulation
these ideas existed but were not
prominent in the mainstream it was only
after algorithms started to perform
before articles that mixed different
injustices together started to perform
well that critical race Theory
intersectionality and these ideas
started to become prominent not because
Academia created them but because social
media manipulation allowed for them to
latch on and rise to the top but
wokeness incorporates more than just
those ideas there's look at look at the
non-binary stuff the the the Envy stuff
you see on on um on Tumblr that is not
born from Academia it's born from 12
year olds who are fed garbage in an
algorithm look at the videos of the
finger family Hitler videos where
Hitler's doing Tai Chi with as a with a
female body with hit well I'm sorry with
the Incredible Hulk that is not born out
of Academia it's born out of algorithms
fed to children children get these
insane ideas from Academia but from a
whole bunch of other places so to put it
mildly I think Academia played a very
outsized role probably the largest role
in the development of a lot of wokeness
but wokeness itself I believe is a
product of algorithms telling you if you
want clicks combine as many rage bait
words as possible like vice's article
where they said trans women of color
being attacked you know being subjects
of police brutality it's Inseparable for
the cause of black lives matter you put
all those things in one link and then
Google shows it to you if you search for
each and any one of those words which
means if you have a community that cares
about police a community that cares
about black lives matter a community
community that cares about trans issues
they will all search for one word and
get a different word but get the same
article so all of these companies were
incentivized to jam all of these words
creating a prominent critical race
Theory and intersectionality of which
many academics now found themselves
reaping the rewards of but they've but
critical race theory has been around for
decades and it wasn't prominent in the
mainstream until algorithms and social
media made it possible and then people
like Jack Dorsey hooked his mouth up to
the toilet the sewer line and started
guzzling down the his own refuse from
his platform and he went from the guy
who said free speech wing of the Free
Speech party I don't think it was him I
think it was one of the other Twitter
guys but you get the point the company
said free speech winning the free free
speech party and then they plugged the
sewer line into their own miles gargled
down the garbage produced by their trash
Network and now they all believe insane
things but to Jack dorsey's credit he
tweeted out rothbard's anatomy of the
state to the to the shock of many
Libertarians let's read more Super
chants I would uh I would disagree a
little bit because I would I would move
the chains back just a little bit
further and I would say wokeness is a
natural extension and a natural
outgrowth of materialism and materialism
arose because of the attacks on
traditional Morality In The West that
once you remove that yes and you only
make the material world the only thing
that matters that all of these things
then arise it's it's the cult of
material we could we can continue to
reduce everything down not that I
disagree with anything well no no but
tactically we could reduce it further
and say how did materialism come to
overtake the United States television
Faith model division modern
manifestations right so so I'm just
saying that you can look at the Lexus
Nexus Data before Facebook and the
ragebait blogs instances of the words
like you know uh critical theory but why
don't we reject it why don't we reject
it out of hand this is so this is the
this is where you get to the point this
is my second see the other if you had
traditional a traditional moral base in
this country right or in the west or a
classic moral base you would reject that
stuff out of hand and it would it would
be it would remain relegated to those
spheres or people look at and say oh
that's silver and if the academies
believed in what they claim to believe
they would have been a Bastion against
wokeness instead they became an
incubator for it 10 years ago this stuff
was laughed off and when the culture War
started ramping up I believe the
gamergate may have been the first major
instance of the culture War many people
said oh you're online too much this is
meaningless what they didn't understand
is that children were put in a in a rage
bait incube innovator where they got
either the anti-sgw side or they got the
sjw side those kids who are 10 years old
in in 2011 are now uh 20 in 2021 and
they're voting and their whole world was
shaped by wokeness on an ever-growing uh
platform 100 the only thing they'd ever
see on these platforms was the rage bait
garbage and now they're getting jobs in
media and the ones who are a little bit
older are getting jobs at the New York
Times and now we are seeing all the
promotions and the emails you have to
put that's right and now companies are
mandating it not because these kids went
to college a lot of people go to college
and complain about this stuff but kids
who who grew up on Tumblr are you know
other kin they believe they're actually
mystical dragons trapped in the body of
an owl that was transported to a human
body in alternate Dimension well maybe
they are Tim maybe they are maybe maybe
to some of them but to put it simply I
think critical race theory was always
there Derek Bell has been saying these
things for a long time he gave a speech
in like 2004 talking about how he was
defending it was the 90s oh yeah yeah he
was defending plus EV Ferguson and other
ridiculous ideas right and nobody cared
like it wasn't it wasn't mainstream it
wasn't on TV it wasn't until social
media uh startups uh uh blog startups
got Venture funding and it's very very
simple
at the dawn of social media when
articles started getting posted on
Facebook two companies would emerge
legitimate news
Huffington Post and they both start
writing articles and legitimate news
articles don't get shared that much but
Huffington Post oh boy you betcha so
Venture Capital steps in and says why
would I invest in them nobody reads it
now they're getting the money and what
were they doing many of these blogs were
they realized they could do police
brutality racial Justice exactly yeah
and then the 10 year old kid who gets on
Facebook spends their entire existence
only being slammed by all of that
content and then the virtue signaling
starts and now all of their friends are
saying I believe these things too don't
you and now they're indoctrinated
reality winner is always one of my
favorite examples of this someone who uh
joins the NSA Becomes of issues Air
Force
um and then
but if you went on her Facebook which
nobody talks about is she was deeply
involved in two things one was yoga and
the other one was russiagate just
everything to do with Russia gate
everything to do with this and then she
finds something at the NSA that you know
kind of sort of it talks about Russia
and Trump Loosely and it's like an
assessment it's not even real Intel but
she says well I've got to leak this
because this proves everything that I've
read on Facebook right so now I can beat
this great hero and this heroic person
and then all of a sudden she learns
about like the Department of Justice
yeah
that's right and she learned about
Progressive journalists at The Intercept
yep what did they do they published the
unredacted uh uh there was I'd have to
go back and look at it but there was
something that they published had enough
of identifying information on the
printer I think it was from the printer
and they were able to actually like they
looked up something they were able to
find yeah they were able to find it was
her identifier all right let's read some
more we got fubadoo he says who cares
what Afghanistan does with China or
anyone else the Taliban is the
government now they have every right to
run the country as they see fit it's not
our problem unless we want more
warmongering
I mean yeah I don't believe America
should be the World Police
I don't want my tax dollars going to
someone being like Oh that country is
doing things I don't like we have so
many Rare Earth minerals right under
American soil that and I know next week
we're probably gonna come on and talk
about that a little bit more but I just
got back from Alaska and I got to tell
you guys if worried about Rare Earth
minerals let me tell you a little story
about a country called the United States
of America and the amount of trillions
and trillions of dollars that we have
literally under our feet or not even
under our feet in the vast wastelands of
the Northern Tier of our country that no
one is using that there is no it's
literally waste I mean you I could show
you a picture you would think it was
Afghanistan if I showed you this picture
but it's you know Parts of Alaska parts
of Montana Etc if Canada as well by the
way
um that no one is using that Wildlife
doesn't care about that we are not
allowed to touch yeah and so the the
reason that it matters is because we're
beholden to so much of this
International
uh in the international economy because
of our stupid policies here at home if
we weren't tied into the international
oil Market why should we care what OPEC
talks about because we could have energy
Independence but we don't so because we
reduced our domestic our domestic
capacity our domestic Supply and so now
we have to go begging to OPEC to please
please you know the oil prices are going
too high could you just have a little
bit more no pigtails tells Biden to
shove off yep I saw we just uh we just
established nuclear fusion ignition I
said that to you last year they actually
didn't do the fusion you don't mean like
you and you guys
oh oh I missed it oh man I think it was
left earlier JPL Lawrence uh National
Livermore uh National Laboratory and
they established the temperatures needed
to uh produce ignition right on so we're
right all right black Czar says
something that is given something that
is given has little value people prize
and take care of what they feel they've
earned this applies to everyone and
everything even to Joe Biden Kamala
Harris and the presidency
Morgan H says not sure if that's the
look Forest is going for but he reminds
me of Sergeant Oddball from Kelly's
Heroes I haven't seen it so I don't know
yeah
what is it someone else super chatted
something similar to
yeah all right I haven't seen it so I
don't know he has like a shrine to it at
home
it's a gypsy Ultra shirt all right Kev
says third time's the charm third time
asking perhaps I will rephrase the
question Tim ask for us about the hnk
MP7 how it pertains to the history of
Recoil magazine and what they had to do
to overcome the cancel culture so that's
a long time before me
uh but early on in in early on in the
history of the magazine there's sort of
a there's a line that you're not
supposed to cross in the Firearms
culture is you're not supposed to tell
people they can't have something
so there's right it's a pretty standard
thing now
um this is one of those things where I
actually get to claim both diplomatic
immunity and I wasn't there and I kind
of don't know about it because it was
like the magazine that came out right
before I found I discovered it but as
far as I understand some people were
frustrated that somebody said the MP7 is
for the military not for you now that
can be interpreted as something like
that I'd need to read the article again
and go back and it was like an opinion
it was it was someone was doing a a
review of the h k MP7 and h k Heckler
and Coke if you're familiar with the
company is notorious for making one
thing for the government and something
else for the people right like their
entire business model is like hey we
made it for the Navy Seals we'll sell
you a non-navy seal version for like
seven Grand
I'm being facetious they make really
good quality stuff but that's what
people like to rag on them for that one
so a very early edition of recoil had an
it had a a review of the MP7 and as far
as I understand
somewhere in that somebody claimed
something that it was well it's only for
the military not for civilian population
now one
I cannot verify it because I don't have
it in front of me but I ca it's a
conversation I can have with the other
editors two that's not the position of
the company
so I don't know what happened and this
is a long time before me but it's a
you're like if you're if you're familiar
with any controversy that's happened
about Recoil magazine that was 10 maybe
15 years ago with a lot of differences
that was before Ian came on Ian
Harrison's the lead editor and that that
guy is somebody where you follow into
battle like he's a good guy to work
under but even more importantly recoil
is not unfamiliar with controversy this
year alone we put maj2ure on the cover
of our magazine in January then we put
Chris Chang on the cover of our magazine
and marshture is in charge of the
organization black lives or black guns
matter very big difference bike guns
matter right dealing with inner city
situations now there's this sort of
left-wing narrative that the gun world
and gun culture is all a bunch of old
white men like first of all you're so
wrong I can't help you I just quite
frankly can't help you like and also if
that's your opinion of American Gun
culture you're not a valuable
participant in the conversation because
yes you know how much what percentage of
the American population is white and
male how many people own fine you can go
down to something and we're not talking
about Equity second part we put Chris
Chang on the cover he's um Chris Chang
represents the lgbtq community and he's
both Chinese and uh he's got both
Chinese and Japanese Heritage and so
Chris Chris Chang's again a really good
representative especially towards
different communities within the United
States in this upcoming edition of
Recoil magazine which the pre-orders
just ended but if you subscribe you can
get it uh Bonnie Rotten is going to be
on the cover and I didn't know who she
was because I'm an innocent boy from
Minnesota oh boy I know right uh so
Bonnie Rotten is an adult actress who
has who has changed her opinion over the
last couple years from
being a pro or from being pro-gun
control to being pro second amendment
rights and even in that and if you want
to call yourself
um you're going to be in 58. so you're
going to be not in the current magazine
that's coming out for recalls got um
Bonnie Rotten on the front and then the
one after that or yeah and 58 which is
the magazine you're going to be
interviewed in that room can we put Tim
on the cover with a throne like the Game
of Thrones throne but made out of guns
if we can make a throne out of guns oh
let's do it yeah oh hey I confirmed you
do look like Oddball it's Donald
Sutherland yeah yeah looks just like
we're in a flight cap which looks like
you're backwards all right he looks
great I look like Oddball I mean young
hey you know yeah you do I could have
thought of worse things to be called
Sutherland's the man hey all right Mike
Mike G says Black Swan event equals the
massive Market correction confirmed by
JP Morgan that is coming AKA to the
mother of all shorts that we Apes have
been talking about for months Stone
Krampus says the Black Swan event will
be the mother of all shorts from
Gamestop Short Selling super stock has
the receipts and a DD I actually can
throw out that uh I agree with that
actually that makes sense the
the White House official that uh that
sends me stuff from time to time was
actually watching the show earlier and
they texted during this and said the
Black Swan event is the Biden
Administration yeah amazing they also
wanted me to say that uh going uh the
Pentagon right now the Joint Chiefs is
basically like the intro of Benny Hill
if you just play that over yeah that
song yeah that's pretty much what's
going on in the government wacky sacks
or whatever
yeah all right
Zim Maru I hope I'm pronounced zimmeru
Forest I was thinking about guns as an
investment is that a good idea if so
what type of guns are the best
investment question
if you are purchasing firearms for the
first time
start with making sure you have a
complete you have at least a handgun and
a carbine that you are that are that are
finished which is a joke and because
you're never done building it your first
gun but
um I do not think it is wise to go out
and just say I'm gonna buy 30 of the
cheapest
insert gun now and then use that in the
future to sell it because first of all
you're dealing with legal issues because
the the idea of purchasing Firearms to
sell them there is some legality to that
and it's muddy and I'm not going to say
it's an easy explanation you could be
purchasing a firearm every month for 30
years and then in 30 years you intend to
put it all together into an estate and
sell it as a group fine there's a
legality to that so our guns as an
individual item and investment yes and
no and it's not a financial decision
that I would have authority over however
if I had bought a hundred thousand
rounds in 2015 I would have made a lot
of money
yeah or you know or or you know
depending on what the market is looking
at right now there are times where you
can buy a firearm in 2019 and sell it in
2021 for a profit so our guns themselves
a good investment on the first question
yes for the sake of your investing into
yourself you're figuring out what it
takes to become lead lethal knowing that
you have rights and responsibilities it
builds character it builds
self-responsibility or self-self self
self sustenance for lack of better words
it builds autonomy and and that those
are things worth investing in so now
that I'm your life coach go buy guns do
the right thing participate in culture
and then if you want to buy a collection
yeah you can you can you can figure out
ways to make money but it's not as easy
as it sounds there's a great meme I saw
I can't remember who posted it so
they're gonna get mad at me but it was a
Facebook post where they said look the
debate is over go out and get it already
it keeps you safe it keeps us it keeps
us all safe it keeps us all safe
everybody knows that communities have
that have gone out and gotten this are
safer they're better protected and it's
the right thing to do there's no
negative effects accidental uh effects
are extremely rare just shut up already
stop debating and go buy a gun yep yep
that was uh
I was reading it and I was like yeah
he's one of these again and then go buy
a fireman I was like
so expectations subverted all right
let's see
fight on Triple Seven says love you guys
can you shout out my recently started
non-profit troops with pause we provide
service dogs to disabled veterans
through dog rescues and educate kids
about the importance of military working
dogs thanks poso and Forest for your
service thank you very cool thank you
cool yeah troops with pause cool sounds
cool uh reach out to if you're still
listening reach out to info
recoilweb.com and we'll get connected
and perhaps we can do some we can see
what you're doing that'd be cool yeah
Cameron says please discuss the
mandatory vaccine counseling already
happening in our military I know
firsthand from my spouse he's asked why
he won't weekly is that something that
they're doing counseling or something no
they're kicking you out of the military
I mean you're or you're being faced with
the choice basically yeah you get this
is that a medical discharge or is it
dishonorable or what it'll probably be a
Medical District it'll probably be a
medical either medical or like
administrative or adcept yeah or or
maybe even even something as simple as
like early retirement we'll just I mean
depending where you are in your career
yeah yeah think about the kind of people
who will be in the military who are just
like sure fine whatever I don't care I
mean and I again like I just said before
you know I talk about this every day
with um you know people in the community
I have a real good friend at jsoc you
know people are saying like hey I I
wanted to serve for another 10 years
another 15 years I've got 10 years
behind me or however much experience
behind me but I don't want to do this
and so you're going to lose all of that
human capital because of this look at it
in comparison to also what a lot of
veterans are feeling with Afghanistan
right now I invested I myself invested
deployment into Afghanistan yeah when we
saw pictures and videos of the embassy
like I knew that area and the government
the government that employed people like
us to go out there
you're you're I mean my inbox right now
of people who either situations like
that or even you know worse talking
about you know my someone I the one I
got today was you know their uh it was
their own I don't want to get it wrong
but it was their um
their daughter-in-law as brother have
been killed there you know when he had
like a five-month-old kid at home right
yeah I mean it's and those those stories
11 years and 11 years and 10 days ago 11
years and 10 days ago I had a team
leader and a friend get killed yeah now
you know I'm this is no longer this is
not for me to carry on them as if like
it adds on to mine because one of them I
got along with and one of them I didn't
and it's not like it was you know
whatever but but what I'm saying there
is yeah there's the tragedy of there
well like what about their sacrifice
we're still starting to get back into
that muddy of it's kind of an emotional
argument because some of us went to war
to go see what it was like and see see
for ourselves firsthand instead of being
told by a news apparatus but the other
part about it is yeah some of us know
interpreters that their family their
lives are in Jeopardy right now that we
worked with them for years and we don't
know where they're going and this is
something that all I want to you know
well I don't wanna I mean it I think
you're okay to say that though it is
emotional that's what we mean it's very
emote and we're a country of people and
this is the last part about it they'll
kind of go into this if I can is you
know to to you who are veterans out
there who reached out to your friends or
to you who are not veterans and reached
out to the people you know who spent
time in Afghanistan like collectively
thank you because this weekend was hard
for a lot of people absolutely because I
def I met I had I got phone calls from
the wives of friends who are hardened
veterans who have spent 15 years in
harsh combat saying I don't know how to
talk to him right now because he doesn't
know how to talk about it right now
because we all went through this
emotional weekend we're still going to
go through it because we don't have
suddenly we don't have the tools where
we can do anything about it
right I can't get on a helicopter and be
like I can't just say one more
deployment we'll go help those guys out
even though that may not may be
misguided whatever well that's what
they're doing right sort of I mean we'll
see right and that's where that's where
I would personally come down on by the
way any Administration that had
conducted this in such a way that was
number one obviously it's chaotic uh and
and ridiculous in what they're doing but
also number two when Biden comes out and
says oh well there wasn't any other
choice there wasn't any other way to do
this it's just have a little bit of an
outlet for the people that did serve and
and and give them something
to show that you understand what they're
going through and so that they feel that
they have a a space where they can come
into and have these discussions you know
something they can fall back on and say
you know we served for this purpose this
is why we did this this is why we put in
those deployments put in that time away
from family away from however many life
events that we had to skip over the
sacrifices that were made both in time
and blood and treasure that it was all
for what and Joe Biden says well you
know there wasn't anything else we could
do yeah part of the hardest thing for me
is that I don't get to go back as far as
I know there's not really any
clean Avenue if I if I were in a
situation where I decided I wanted to go
back to Afghanistan I can't right I mean
we don't know what the future holds but
mostly not C Hennessey says we need a
progressive tax system for corporations
based on Manufacturing in the U.S with a
backstop that five percent of deduction
can't be deducted unless they are 100 in
the states 100 for it yeah interesting
idea 100 for productionism baby
all day long
libertarian shook oh I love it when they
just jump on me like that all right
let's see what's the super jump
all right let's see
okay oh okay Scott Anderson says parts
for two 50 bmgs were found in the
wreckage referring to Waco both were in
a disassembled State lacking enough
parts to build a fully functional rifle
they had barrels but lacked almost
everything else
interesting they were still used to
shoot down a helicopter I mean I believe
he said the ATF said so I mean Biden the
trustworthy guy you know who you know
who who lives by the creative critical
race theories which was definitely a
truth finding who's whose son certainly
follows all gun laws to to the letter
absolutely
these people aren't Hypocrites they just
don't like you
all right let's see
Rob Ingram says where's Jack Murphy been
no Luke we puke no Ian weeping no Jack
we Yak
Ian's right here what are you talking
about yeah he's still it yeah where's
Jack Murphy that big muscle-bound honk I
think
I don't know I think it's just he's just
not here
yeah
Luke is doing like survival classes and
I keep I keep like we have all these
opportunities for Luke I'm like Luke hey
we're gonna have this person we're gonna
have that person you gotta come you'll
be great and he's like oh I can't I
can't I can't he's busy he's got the
first they're all sleeping
sleeping on their fallacious my pillows
having used promo code where do I get
one of those no no well if you go to
mypillow.com and use promo code Pozo
p-o-s-o p-o-s-o you can get at your very
own my pillow this is a king-size my
pillow they do have smaller ones but
there are there are different levels of
firmness I do like that about them uh I
don't actually know which firmness this
one is oh there's a medium there's a
medium firmness he brought up my pillow
again yes
once again well they're good we'll talk
about that pillow afterwards because the
pillow that I'm currently used was
stolen from Iraq in 2009 wow
all right let's see
summer uh Arbogast says listen to you
every morning on Spotify thank you for
letting me know I'm not alone in this
you got it yeah uh Gina Carano tweeted
You Are Not Alone
yeah but uh I tell you this man with
what's going on in New York
the Nazis went for the disabled first
the Nazis claimed that Jewish people had
typhus and that's why they needed to be
separated and marked and so whenever I
bring these things up you know first
people go Godwin's law I don't care I'll
violate Godwin's law which of course for
those unfamiliar is that all internet
arguments eventually devolve to the
point where someone accuses the other
person of being a Nazi and I tell them
do you think that when the Nazis Rose to
power they immediately just snapped
their fingers and said hear the trains
everyone have a board or do you think it
was oh we have to do this because you
know for this reason and oh there's
there's disease we have to oh I'm sorry
and then they were just escalating and
ramping up the rhetoric and the other
and so anathematization this is the
point I was making earlier this week
when Arnold Schwarzenegger was doing
whatever podcast he was on and he said
screw your freedoms right screw your
freedoms and I made the point of saying
that oh did you you know I like to do
like historical context for people that
Arnold Schwarzenegger's father right not
someone who's like you know barely
distantly associated with him his father
was a member of the brown shirts a car
carrying member of the Nazi party of
Austria and then eventually served in uh
in the where Mark and was actually
wounded in the Battle of Stalingrad so
he was he was a a decorated member of
the Nazis right and I posted that up my
post was banned from Instagram for
saying that because it said that I was
posting about extremist organizations
even though
even though it was I was simply making a
point about Arnold Schwarzenegger and
yes yes Newsweek comes out fact checks
the whole thing and said to be clear
Arnold Schwarzenegger's father was
definitely a Nazi not to be fair to be
fair I will not condemn someone for the
sins of the father nor will they condemn
them for their own sins of saying screw
your free exactly but the point I was
making was it's like you know the apple
and the tree kind of situation right
right right to add some utility to
Godwin's law is uh if you must if you
are dealing with the situation where it
is the Nazis ask yourself was it wrong
because the Nazis did it or were the
Nazis wrong because they did it great
question because the Nazi it was the
segregation of people that made was part
of making the Nazis wrong right so it
doesn't matter
who does it it's wrong what they did
my friends smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
go to timcast.com be a member we're
gonna have a bonus members only segment
up by about 11 p.m you can follow the
show at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast do you guys want
to shout anything out uh humanevents.com
go to humanevents for all your breaking
news especially on what's going on on
the shade war between Joe Biden
and the vice president waiting the wings
and for something a little bit closer to
home recoil web for your Firearms
off-grid web for anything survival based
and then if you want to subscribe to any
of our magazines you can do that from
those and then finally if you want to
follow me personally my Instagram is at
foxro underscore official and then we
have recoil and both or both recall and
off-grid have their own
um Instagram Pages as well so very cool
cool I want to point out these uh
amazing rocks
that's not a rock this is rose quartz
crystal it's Crystal this is Crystal I
don't know that's technically a rock or
not and uh this is a bad promotion so
far what is this pyrite Yep this is
fool's gold this is what it's like
polish insert Tim took a big crew and
went to a rock shop a local rock
Emporium and oh no it's more magical
than that we went to the mall for no
reason and in the dark back Corners we
discovered a rock store where they had
like fossils and giant quartz spheres
they have something called TV Stone it's
where they they believe that fiber
optics were invented it's a rock with a
bunch of like fibers and when two fibers
yeah when you take it it's thick and you
put it as a lens it looks like a TV
screen it pulls the image to the front
so when you're holding it you put your
finger on the back you can see the
fingertip as if it's like several inches
in front of you and so that's the
concept for fiber optics right so it's
amazing and they also had optical
citrine I believe it is or Sunstone that
when you put it over uh when you when
you look through it everything doubles
and you can spin it and the image moves
this this store was fantastic well it's
all captured on video uh cast Castle the
YouTube channel it's in the today's Vlog
so check it out it was incredibly
entertaining we're going to start doing
Vlog we're ramping up to the point where
we're doing Vlogs every single day so
we've added a whole bunch of people and
uh it is not a personal Vlog as some
people have tried to argue because I'm
not going to beat it all that often if
I'm in it a lot now it's basically just
the house and everybody and you know I'm
available probably only a few minutes
every day to pop in when I do so we'll
see one of the things we're planning
right now now is we're going to make
we're going to take fungus bread with a
mushroom with fungus based cheese
to make a fungus sandwich and they have
fungus based ice cream so we're going to
do a whole mushroom thing all right all
right yeah so uh yeah let me make sure
we were doing that so I uh
no it's gonna be awesome
portobello burger is so good all right
Portobello follow me at Ian Crossland on
the internet and uh I'd love to see you
and I think we just discovered what the
Black Swan event's gonna be yeah
you guys may follow me at Sour Patch
Kids Sour Patch Lids don't follow Sour
Patch Kids I'm trying to beat them in
followers I'm really sad that I missed
out on this rock shop I freaking love
going to rock shows my favorite rocks
are labradorite tanzanite and savorite
which you guys should look up I think we
have labradorite I think we do I almost
brought it gorgeous one of my favorites
yeah you were you weren't with us were
you no no somebody was like labradorite
we saw the rock shop and Andreas was
like maldivite and they were like we
have maldivite it's a meteorite and so
we got good things they have a bunch of
meteorite and I asked the guy how much
meteorite would I need to craft a sword
it looked like I I I it looked like I
smacked him he was like oh you'd have to
destroy so much meteorite to do that and
I was like okay okay I won't buy tens of
thousands of thousand meteorite to craft
a sword yeah so before I go I know we're
trying to wrap up here but my favorite
author actually was knighted by the
queen and he made his sword out of a
meteorite so that she can night him it's
very cool crazy all right everybody
smash that like button don't forget to
go to timcast.com because we will see
you all in the members only segment
coming up at about 11 or so p.m so
thanks for hanging out bye guys